From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is August 13th, 2013. This is David Klein speaking. I am a professor of history at Virginia Tech, also working for the Smithsonian Institute's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Today we are interviewing Judge D'Army Bailey here in Memphis, Tennessee. Behind the camera is John Bishop of UCLA and Media Generation.
We will begin now. Thank you so much for being part of this project.
I'm honored for the opportunity.
As I started to say off camera, I wanted to start with a couple of questions before we get into the really Euro-bifestory and your story in the movement.
And if I could, the first question is, what is the difference between an activist and a radical?
An activist is a person who devotes energies to make and change to some project or some issue that that person is dedicated to.
A radical is a person who's also devoted in terms of their energies to make and change, but they are not bound by the same parameters that an activist is.
The radical sees beyond the acceptable barriers for action and conversation and bangs against the outer walls to make progress much farther than is institutionally conceived.
Now, being a realist, even though you're doing that and you're trying to open new horizons beyond acceptable boundaries, the end result is that you're lucky if you get to those walls.
But the activists, I think, short-sells themselves or herself by accepting the boundaries and therefore, because you're never going to achieve everything that you're seeking.
The radical, we posit concepts and agendas for change that in reality, we don't expect to achieve.
But we're dedicated to it, we fight for it as if we believe that we will and that's what keeps us going and makes dramatic change.
And I think you probably appreciate why I started asking you that question, especially because of the subtitle of your autobiography and I think, do you think of yourselves in those terms in terms of being both an activist and a radical or different things at different times or a radical?
Well, actually, I generally as two labels, we used that label for the book, the education of a black radical. And when I was in politics in California, I and the other two of my colleagues who were elected to the council were dubbed by the media as being radicals and it was called a radical takeover of the Berkeley, California City Government.
And so I've had that label attached to me. I have, I never used that myself in terms of definition when I was out there. And I really don't use it much today, but I do accept that that's a fair definition of me and my politics.
And I don't like labels, it's simply because it makes you more easily pigeonholed and therefore you're much easier target for those who want to discount what you're trying to do by attaching you with label.
When I was involved in civil rights in Baden Rouge, my friends were in court, the Congress of Racism Quality and they were big supporters of what we were doing. But it took me the longest of time before I was willing to join court because I just don't personally like to associate myself with the denifiable groups where I can then be limited in terms of how people perceive me or what I can do.
Right, right, very interesting. Thank you. And then the other big question I want to ask before we get into the biography is, how do you define the civil rights movement? I mean, our project here is called the Civil Rights History Project.
And there, there's a sort of traditional take on what the civil rights movement is, which is often bounded by or focused on Dr. Martin Luther King.
But I was very struck at the National Civil Rights Museum that you were a founder of, that the story, you begin the story much earlier, basically starting with the story of slavery and coming up to the very present day.
I'm interested in how you see the movement as a, is it a much longer battle on many fronts than we sometimes see in the history books as the 1955 to 1968.
Well, the earlier context going back to slavery and the abolitionist movement, I can't really claim a great deal of credit for envisioning that as a preliminary to the logic exhibits at the museum.
That was a broad context that was created in collaboration with some very excellent designers, including Benjamin Lawless, who had helped us to lay out much of the plan.
But I brought to the creation of the museum my experience in the civil rights movement.
We had bought the Lorraine Motel at a foreclosure auction. I knew that it was a place that people would come from around the world because that's where Dr. King's blood still can be seen on the concrete walkway outside of the room where he last slept.
To me, it was a way of taking the magnetism of the death of King, but not creating a museum about King.
The museum that I wanted to create, and it was in large part the sense of my own experiences in the movement that helped to set the path for what the museum was to be because having come as a young college student in 1960 to the beginning of the time,
the beginning of the city in Baton Rouge, and then having traveled down to Atlanta and visited with the snake leaders and been out into Rueville and sat down with Fannie Lou Hamer on our front porch and been at some of the great marches and dramatic scenes in Oven, Bogalusa, where the Deacon's for Defense and Justice had to meet us and escort us into town and protect us while we were there.
I knew the intensity of that movement, and I also knew that the Civil Rights Movement was not King. It was not any singular leader, even such a great person as a James Fama, who was equally very much important to that struggle.
But rather it was the combination of individuals, those young students that I saw who inspired me as another student who were willing to put the education on the line, to go to jail, to have their families worry about them, in some cases, their economic security being threatened, their families are security because their students were involved.
And I saw the courage of these people, and as I would go to these rallies and participate in them and hear the music, that's why we have an exhibit about the music of the Civil Rights Movement, the snake freedom singers.
Of course, you know, Fannie Lou Hamer was a very great singer at these meetings. I've heard her sing and Pete Seeger and Pete Seeger.
And so all of that was a part of the spirit, even Anne Fagan and Braden, rather, and Carl Braden. Well Carl Braden, I came to meet when I was thrown out of school at Southern, and she was editing the Southern Patriot newspaper out of Kentucky.
She would send us words of encouragement and a few dollars here to help us. So it was a whole broad range of people that I saw Will D. Campbell up in from Mount Juliet, who recently passed, who was a mentor to me in helping to understand the spirit of human struggle.
I spent about three weeks at the University of Wisconsin in 1961 at a Southern student here in relation to Seminaw, where there were 18 students, half black and half white, sponsored by the National Students Association.
And we were studying race issues, and we were bringing in speakers and Will D. Campbell and Connie Curry, whether two leaders of those sessions for us. And we got to know each other. Bob Zelner, for example, who later became a leader in SNCC, was one of my members of that group there at the University of Wisconsin.
So it was the process of learning, of studying, of being on the scene. And so to me the civil rights movement was the cold-dewon within which you had this extraordinary mix of spirit, of courage, of people from different backgrounds.
And most importantly, young blacks, we were the first generation from our families that went to college. And we didn't go off to college at these black state universities in the South with the intention of creating civil rights movement.
It was completely accidental that the movement happened in my first year of college, and that I became exposed to it. We went off to have a good time to educate ourselves for better opportunities in the world of business and growth.
But we were aware. And so I guess I'll also have to look back a little bit in terms of the definition of the movement because it was not just what happened in 1960 with the students at Greensboro.
I would remember as a young teenager sitting in a drug store where I delivered ice cream and things to people in the neighborhood on my bicycle, who would order it at the store.
But when I wasn't working there, I would sit and look at the magazine rack where we had jet magazine and ebony and black newspapers from Detroit and in the land of the daily world.
And I would read about the civil rights movement and I saw the picture of Emmett Till when he'd been killed in his bloated body was exhibited in the cask at night.
And being in Memphis, which was so close to these hot spots of Mississippi, I saw those kids over in Little Rock at Central High School and the courage that they showed. And these were kids my age.
And so my civil rights movement, not as I defined it, but as it defined me, was a movement that started probably in the 1950s with the killing of Emmett Till with the students at Central High School in Little Rock with, you know, somewhat more distant way, the Montgomery Bus Borough Cot.
And so when we were setting about to build the museum, the primary story, and that's why the exhibits there, the primary exhibits in the museum, start with the Central High School, well, it starts with Brown versus Peacock with a large exhibits there because the 54 decision was a pivotal one.
But I don't think that the 54 decision was the fuel that ignited the spirit of Black America. I think that the CNN Emmett Till's body and CNN's Black kids. Now, of course, that came as a result of the 54 decision.
But it was the hard work, the groundwork that had been done by Daisy Bates with the NAACP there in Little Rock who had the courage to help those kids to go to school, the courage of all of this movement.
And so, do you remember your actual reaction to that to them until photograph or your reaction, but also other people in the community?
Quiet shock. I can't say that I was completely surprised. Nor was I overtaken with strong emotion about this because it was an education, it was a wake-up call, more than a shock, I guess.
It was a wake-up call that we've got some hell of a struggle ahead of us here if this is what they'll do to these young kids, to my people, to me. That this is serious business.
And so it detoured me very quickly as did what I saw those kids at Central High School do and go through.
It made quick men and women strong and it began to prepare us for what lay ahead.
It's interesting because you were young people who was happening to young people.
Yes.
And it was no platitude to say it could happen to me. I would get on the bus when I was going to Southern and I'd take the train from Memphis to Hammond, Louisiana and get off there and then I'd have to take a bus from Hammond over to Baton Rouge.
And I would sometimes be sitting in the front section of the bus because I knew that the law was that they couldn't segregate me but I'd be the only black sitting up there in the front.
And then as the bus stopped in these little small towns and this was in 1960, 1961, why to get on and they would refuse to take the seats behind me.
And so they'd be standing in the aisles. And I would just be there in the seat and pretend that I was sleeping and just turning going about my business.
But I was an interstate bus.
Interstate bus.
And because they would have signs in the bus stations that said whites, white women, white men and colored and the white sign actually would say whites and interstate passengers.
But they'd also have signs that say colored and of course they didn't differentiate between colored men and colored women.
And so even though by law, since I was traveling from one state to the other they couldn't segregate me but in reality you were in quite some danger.
And I would even go on the buses from Baton Rouge to Atlanta at sometimes alone and why did that and where I had the courage to do that.
Because I could have easily ended up missing.
But maybe I was just crazy like that.
I don't know.
But I just felt that I was not born to lead my life letting fear overcome my dignity.
It wasn't that I wasn't afraid. But it was the question of which would went out.
And so as I would go into these places, I was shaking in my boots as it goes.
But they didn't know it.
Right. Right. Right. Couldn't have let them see that.
Yeah. Yeah.
Would you mind telling us a little bit about your your mother and father and the influence?
Oh, I should have felt. I have a little time to say.
We have to close the following once again, get some bigger and bigger in the Queen.
Anything happens who lose at all.
Yeah. So.
So if I could ask you to tell us a little bit about your your parents and their maybe their influence and in this regard.
And I I know a little bit about what they did for work and that there's a story there as well.
So I think about independent African Americans and the tradition of the Poland porters for example.
So could you tell us a little bit about that?
Well, it was a struggle for both my mother and father, neither of whom finished high school.
They got married while they were both in high school.
And so my daddy went to work with his father who was doing a building and repairing houses.
And my grandfather was sort of an entrepreneur after whom I'm named.
And so in Tennessee?
Yes. Although he was born in Mississippi near Shelby County near the Tennessee Lion Act.
And so when I was growing up my mother was my earliest work that I remember her doing was as a housekeeper at a medical clinic with a doctor's office.
And they treated her very well. I mean they they treated her with respect.
She would even double as a receptionist at the clinic.
Although these were white doctors and their clientele was white.
But she was basically a maid but she was respected and she carried herself with dignity when she was there at the clinic.
And she worked with Dr. Seagerson.
And she was a DC Seagerson who was the physician.
And I remember that following her work at the clinic.
And we would go visit my brother and I sometimes.
And we were again, we would treat it with respect.
My grandfather in addition to the work that he did in his own business, put me.
And grandfather, Papa as we called it, would work for two white women, sisters who were wealthy.
And they let him plant cotton on the back field of their yacht as well as peanuts.
And so again they treated Papa with a great deal of respect.
And so my early experience, both in terms of my mother, my grandfather.
My father, as I said, was working with my grandfather in those early years.
Following the early work with his father, he started working for the railroad here in Memphis.
He worked as a male handler.
So he would unload the mail from the trains onto Cots at the station.
He was able to initially get promoted up to work as a train porter, first pot time.
And then he got a full time position with Illinois Central Railroad.
And daddy worked the line from New Orleans to Chicago.
And so he'd get on the train here in Memphis and then he'd go Chicago and then back to New Orleans
and then come back and get off here at Memphis.
And as a result of him working with the railroad, we could travel free.
My brother and I and my mother and of course my daddy.
And so he would take my brother and me to foot, not to baseball games.
Go to St. Louis and Chicago and Detroit.
He'd take us over to St. Louis and I saw some of the early black stars, Jackie Robinson and the R.I.P. now.
And we were just kids. We stayed in a little black hotel there in St. Louis.
My mother always respected the maturity of my brother, Walter and me.
And so we had some latitude in terms of what we could do as young people.
We could go out at night and party and late and bar my dad is caught.
Because we acted responsibly.
She knew that both my brother and I were working with some black political people here
doing political campaigns in the late 50s and early 60s, even as we were early on in college.
And so there was no criticism of that.
Were they involved in all your parents?
Were they just supportive of your work activity?
No, they were not politically, I mean they were voters.
They were not organizationally active.
Now my mother was, she went back to school and got her GED.
Then she got licensed as a Baba.
And so she was one of the first black female Babas in Memphis.
And then she did that for a short while, well, a short while, it was probably four or five years.
And a Babishop in the center of the black neighborhood in South Memphis, Mississippi and Walker, where we grew up.
And after four or five years of cutting hair, she went back and got her license as a nurse
and became a licensed practical nurse and worked first at what she was one of the first black nurses at St. Joseph Hospital here in Memphis.
And worked for many years, ultimately retiring from nursing.
My father, he was an addition to being a train porter.
He liked to play checkers and pools, so he had a lot of friends and he was outgoing.
Very proud of his two sons.
But he was probably a bit more cautious, or savvy, I should say.
And therefore, he didn't particularly urge us to be shaking at trees or rocking the boat.
I remember that when we would go down to the train station, again on the train, to go down to Baton Rouge.
When you got to go up onto the train, the conductor would ask you, where were you going?
I would say Baton Rouge, Hammond, and they would say to the left, where the blacks were being sent, where the whites were being sent.
So it didn't really matter where you were going.
But I would sometimes, if my father wasn't there, I'd go to the right and to the white section and sit down.
But typically, if he was with me, my mother and I, then I wouldn't get them to upset about doing that.
But they knew that Walter and I, Walter was a football player and a very good one.
So he was with the jocks, to some extent, in the early years he later decided, in part, because of the civil rights efforts that were going on,
and he had been put off campus when I was expelled from southern because of my activities.
They lodged him in a dormitory of married students, number one were law students, and that's how you got interested in a career in law.
But my mother was supportive when I was expelled from southern in my junior year, and I called her and told her about it, and she was very calm.
She took things calmly, and my father did as well. He was very supportive.
But I guess it was the calmness and the serenity and elegance in some ways, quiet of my mother and the strength of my father.
But she really kind of nurtured, I think, in her own way, not by advocacy, but by supporting us, the sense of independence that I developed and that my brother developed.
And even before you went to southern, you were involved in some local organizations, right, with the NAACP and in Shelby County.
Can you tell us a little bit about what those organizations were doing at that time?
The Memphis Blacks did not have a big challenge to vote in Memphis, because for many years in the 1940s and into the 1950s, Memphis was run by a political boss, one of the nations's premier bosses, E.H. "Boss" Crump.
And the Crump machine controlled politics not only in Memphis, but across the state of Tennessee.
Part of his strength came from the Black vote. And so Crump would have certain people that were his lieutenants in the Memphis Black community that would help Corral and deliver the Black vote for him.
These lieutenants would in turn be influential so that if Black people needed a job or needed some content, then they could go to these lieutenants.
So the Blacks were able to vote in Memphis early on when the Crump machine went into its decline in the early 1950s, about the mid-50s, there was no longer a Crump machine, but you had a tradition of voting among Blacks.
Now the NAACP was the premier Black political organization doing that time, composed of some Black business owners and professionals, but also a lot of Reik and Fowl Blacks were constituted in NAAC.
And that was about the only really noticeable civil rights group here, there wasn't a SNCC or a core as well at the time.
And the NA was a little bit more cautious in its strategies than some of the groups that emerged in the civil rights movement, such as core and SNCC.
So to that extent, the thrust of the NAACP was into the political arena, working with a group of Black Democrats that formed the Shelby County Democratic Club.
And that was the strongest Black political organization here, during the time that I was growing up as a teenager.
And so my brother and I worked as volunteers with the Democratic Club going to their meetings.
We would go out on the sound trucks or to any elections and speak on the microphone and on the sound trucks and put out literature in the neighborhoods,
origin votes for White candidates that were not segregationists.
And those days we supported White candidates primarily on the basis of whether they were for or against racial segregation.
And these would have been liberals or moderates at the time.
So the Democratic Club was very active in supporting those candidates and then began to support some trailblazing Black candidates.
And so in the late 50s, there were at least a couple of Black candidates, Dr. Walker, J. Walker, who ran for the school board.
He was one of the leading Black businessmen and also Russell Sugarmon, who ran for the Commission of Public Works.
And that became sort of those races, particularly the Shigman race, became sort of caused celebrities because there was a good chance that Shigman could have won,
except that the White community coalesced to force out some of the White candidates in order to focus their support around one who was Bill Ferris, because there was no runoff and they were fearful that if they didn't do that, Shigman would win.
So that became kind of, I guess, in a way my first introduction to the politics and also the politics of race.
And they were inextricably bound together in the late 50s.
And so Memphis, the way of civil rights in the late 50s was more of a political effort than it was openly race-based.
So by the time I came through high school here and left in 59 off to college, Memphis was still sharply segregated.
The amusement park, we could only go to the amusement park on Tuesdays.
And if the Tuesday was a holiday, then we couldn't go. We'd have to wait until the fall and we could go to White to go.
The same thing with the city zoo, we'd go on Thursdays.
And the schools were still segregated. The buses were segregated. So right on to the end of the 1950s,
the racer had not been tackled directly here in Memphis as it had began to be tackled in say Montgomery with the bus for a card in 55 and 56.
But even those White candidates that you described the Black community as...
I am.
Perfect.
Part two, part three.
So even the White political candidates of the African American community did support because they weren't strict segregationists,
they weren't really dismantling the system.
No, they were not.
But that was dramatic to have a commission candidate or to have a candidate for Senate, which we did.
In fact, he won. He served only a short time.
Ross Bass, a Democrat, a George W. Grider who won a seat for Congress.
And again, they were not pro-segregationists. They were not pro-entit...
Well, they spoke in terms of the need for change.
And that was all we could expect. But basically, they were not...
Tilton had dramatic change in the system of racism that we saw here.
But those were... But these were the baby steps that were necessary.
And they were important to us at the time.
Okay. And so that was what's... The Shelby County Democratic Club.
And the NAACP, was there a youth organization here in Memphis?
No, not at that time.
That's why my brother and I, who were...
who were ordinarily in today's time, would have been part of the youth organization.
And I think that it was good that there wasn't a youth organization.
I mean, we were thrown in there with the seasoned strategist and we were in the meetings with them.
And we were treated not as youth, but we were...
We were treated. In fact, one summer, I worked for the club and the sheriff...
Sheriff Hines, who was a white sheriff here.
I got paid for doing my work with the club by the sheriff's office because the club was supporting the sheriff.
And so he hired me as...
And I don't know, I might have gotten 40 dolls a week, which was an ice-low stipend.
And my job was to go out and find bootleggers and let them know who was selling corn whiskey out in the county areas.
And so I'd go out to the bootleggers and buy a half-pain of corn liquor when every was time for me to go get my check and take it down there.
And tell the sheriff they was still out there and give him my half-pain of whiskey and get my check and keep on going.
But that was support. That was how...
That was the nature of the give and take of our relationships that helped us to get things done.
So you had your eyes open to help politics really work out of young age.
Yeah, very interesting.
And so when you went on to college at Southern in Baton Rouge, you came down there as things were beginning to happen politically down there with some experience.
Yes.
And in fact I ran for President of Freshman Class at Southern and was elected.
And which was actually a good feat because I was now the state or most of the vast majority of the students at Southern were from Louisiana.
And our class was probably about somewhere between 12 and 1500 students.
So it gave me a forum and opportunity to speak out with the students.
And again, at the beginning when I was elected President of Freshman Class, it wasn't a civil rights agenda.
Although I was becoming aware of what was happening in South Africa because they had had the massacre in Johannesburg, which is a black activist.
And so I was beginning to at least sense not just the national thrust of change, but the international by the drama of these people being massacred over there in South Africa.
And I talked a little bit about that on campus. I wrote a column in the campus newspaper.
I didn't do that until my second year at Southern.
But I was beginning to emerge, I guess, as a student leader on the campus, but not with any defined agenda.
But just working with other students to have nice parties.
I brought in a band from Memphis, which was great for the people in Baton Rouge, because they'd never seen a great rhythm in Blues band.
Like I brought in, they came in with their trailers. I mean, I don't mean these big trailers. I mean, trailers on the back are cause of Gene Bollegs Miller and just put on a hell of a show there.
I brought off the price stock to a period one of our dancers.
Because Walter and I, when we were teenagers, I mentioned that my parents would tolerate us going out.
We'd actually go to some of the adults, I mean, some of the mature clubs, night clubs, and Drake Whiskey and listen to the music.
But we would come back and we would handle ourselves responsibly.
So I was already introduced to the entertainment circuit.
And I just brought in some of those entertainers, at least like that band anyway, that I brought from Memphis.
And of course, I didn't have any pre-biscontak with off the price stock, but we brought in there as well.
So it wasn't just political that I was engaged in when I was at Southern.
I was just, as I said, a student leader having a good time and enjoying Louisiana.
It was a nice change for me, the environment, the students were at beautiful women.
Southern had some of the most beautiful co-ets of any college on the black college circuit.
And they had a great band, a Southern university band.
So it was a great experience for me in my first year there.
And what year was that?
59.
Okay.
Alright.
And then Greensboro happened that month.
Well, that February.
Yeah, that spring, right?
And I didn't know, but within a month or two of that, some students from Southern went and got arrested.
And we didn't know that we mean in most of the students that they were planning to do this.
And that was a real eye-opener to us, not just that they'd gone down in and been arrested.
But then when they were released on bond and got back to the campus and the administration chose to expel them from school.
And this is, they had sat, can you tell us just a little bit about what they did?
They sat in the room.
Yeah, they went and sat in at some lunch counters in downtown Baton Rouge.
And they were arrested.
And Charles would disturb in a piece.
In fact, the first group, Paul and the death, that led to the first US Supreme Court decision,
a Gonaverse in the state of Louisiana, that affirmed the right of demonstrators and paved the way
for many of the subsequent demonstrators to proceed without being prosecuted.
And the basis of the Gona case, Gonaverse in Louisiana, was that these Southern students had been arrested in downtown Baton Rouge.
And the state had accused them of disturbing the piece.
And the Supreme Court decision was that, and the theory of disturbing the piece was that they were peaceful.
They went and sat at lunch counters, but that they would stir other people, white people up,
who would attack them, and that was disturbing the piece.
And the Supreme Court said in that decision, reversing the convictions because they were convicted at state level,
that you cannot be convicted of disturbing the piece because you're a peaceful conduct
for both someone else to engage in an unlawful conduct against you.
And so that was a pioneer in case it came out of the first year of demonstrations there at Southern.
I'll work some, yeah, you could charge someone with inciting a riot, I guess, by being peaceful.
Yeah, in fact two Supreme Court decisions came out of two years later because the Gona decision was rendered.
The kids were arrested in 1960, but the decision wasn't rendered until 1961, which was pretty quick for the Supreme Court.
But that came out in the autumn of 1961.
And so later that fall, the students of Southern started demonstrating again.
And I was then part of a large demonstration of students that marched into downtown Baton Rouge in December of 1961.
And we were tear gasped and dogs were set upon us, and some of our leaders were arrested.
And one of our leaders who had been an organizer for the Congress of Race and Quality, Reverend Rev. B. Elton Cox,
was arrested there that day.
And that led to a second Supreme Court decision, Cox v. Louisiana, in which the Supreme Court reversed the Cox conviction.
And the accused Reverend Cox violating a Louisiana law that said that he couldn't demonstrate in a courthouse, that he would be intimidation.
And the Supreme Court actually went through some, it was a divided opinion of the court.
And they ended up reversing the conviction by saying that, well, he actually had permission of the police.
And I know that he didn't have permission of the police because we got stopped twice.
And the first time the police officers told him, my brother and I were right at head of the line with Reverend Cox, as we formed around the old state capital in Baton Rouge.
And we were getting ready to march, and the police captain came over and spoke to Reverend Cox and said, turn these students around.
And he said, well, we came here to march and we're going to be peaceful. So we started out to march and they stopped him again.
And they said, now you've had your say, now I'm going to have nine, I want you to turn these students around.
And Cox said, we're going to proceed to jail, we're peaceful.
And so he stopped him twice. Well, the Supreme Court took that as being that he had gotten permission to carry on the demonstration at the courthouse.
Well, he was violating the order of the police, what he was doing. But they let us go on to the, because at that point they either could break us up and start arresting us or let us go on to the courthouse to jail because it was both the jail and courthouse.
And we were really going to the protest because our students were in jail down there. But the arrests was based on the fact that we were at a courthouse.
And that was a state law? Yeah. And so that changed that.
Right. And so that changed that. Well, yes, well, it changed it. I don't know. It didn't really, the court danced around it because as judges themselves, they didn't want to hold the court.
So that's why they did this, this flip flop about, well, he had the permission. So it really wasn't a violation of the statute.
Okay. So they didn't say also the statute. No, they didn't over turn the statute.
Very interesting.
Yeah. Because of course the courthouse is a potent symbol and a commonplace to demonstrate. Yes.
And the court one, you could tell from the opinion, if you ever read Cox v. Louisiana that they certainly didn't want to say that you could come up on the courthouse steps and protest.
Right. Right.
So you were involved in those protests and the result of your involvement in that was what? Absolutely.
Well, by the time of my junior year, because the first wave of protests that happened in 1960 upon the, in the wake of the Greensboro Cityans, did not yield any breakdown in segregation.
The restaurants continued segregated. And things quieted down because the expulsion of the student leaders continued.
That summer was really my first venture outside of the South where I was in an interracial setting when I went to the National Convention of the United States National Students Association as one of the two delegates from Southern.
And these were student leaders from around the country, black and white, including many from the South.
And there was a great debate going on at that convention because the Southern schools were mad that the leadership of the National Student Association had endorsed the city in movement.
And they wanted to reverse that decision. And so the entire convention was overwhelmed with the debate about whether to support the city in movement.
And which the convention ultimately did. But here I was on this campus with some of the best student leaders, both conservative and liberal from across the country, arguing about the issue of the city in protest and not to provide.
This was where I got at the University of Minnesota on the campus of the University of the summer of 1960.
And that's where I got to meet people like Alut and Einstein and Tom Hayden, Barney Frank was a student in Hobbit at the time in one of the outspoken supporters of the city in movement fighting against the Southern schools that wanted to reverse the endorsement.
I mentioned that because not only was this my exposure to white activists, but it also was for me anyway the pivotal chance to see that the student activism, you see, it was a whole different climate at that time.
Not just black students now, but white students, National Student Association was a strong national organization based in Philadelphia that had a budget.
It had a lobbyist in Washington that was working to lobby Congress on issues that the students took positions on.
And then, Alut and Einstein, who later went to Congress, was one of the sort of he wasn't a student at the time, but he was very close to the students.
And he was sort of one of the liaison between the student association. So we had a national student group there.
NSA also had its international wing that was called the, well, it was the international division, which later was associated in some kind of support from the CIA and it was an embarrassment to the NSA from that.
But the national section of the NSA was not caught up in that. But I saw in my two years of conventions at the NSA some of the, again, some of the great issues and debates at the time that was when Huwack, there was a big debate about the House Committee on Un-American activities.
And they had had the demonstrations out there and there was a film that was put out by Fulton Lewis III, an attempted to brand all of the activists as communist.
I can't remember this film now, but they were going around the country trying to persuade people that this was all a communist plan among the students.
They were all great debate on the Wisconsin campus in the summer of 61, the following year after I had done this seminar there.
So I mentioned those things to say that by the time I was in my junior year at Southern, my horizon had expanded in terms of understanding the national and even the international dimension, but particularly the national dimensions of this movement.
And it was not just then confined to the energy of Southern black students, but it was confined to the supportive energy of white students from different parts of the country.
And so I could see a strong movement that I knew was there at last and it did last.
And so I came out of NSA, came the Port Huron meeting of the students and the formation of the students of the Democratic Society.
In fact, I have one of the original Port Huron statements among my papers.
And that was of course the statement by those who gathered at the Port Huron Michigan to give sort of their treaties on the things that needed to be changed to America.
So again, if you think in the context of what makes a radical, those who gathered at Port Huron informed the students of the Democratic Society.
And again, I knew many of these people. I wasn't at Port Huron, but I was close enough to these people in their thinking and my associations with them, not just at these conventions, but in later meetings because I would go back to when I was in Massachusetts up to Yale and we would meet on the campus there and student leaders would come from different parts of the North together.
But when I was in my junior year at Southern, protest broke out again by the time of that decision and the Cox case and Cox was arrested and prosecuted and that was in December of 61.
And the president closed the school, the president of university and ordered everybody home early for the holidays.
When the school reopened, we still had a number of about 20 of our students still in jail that had caused us to go down and protest to begin with.
And so we started a boardcott on the campus because we wanted to be assured that these students were not going to be expelled.
And so we started rallies and the administration asked us not to do that. And they called me to the Dean of Men's office one night, my brother and me, and the Dean of Men talked to me and told me that if I spoke at the rally that we had planned the next rally, that I was going to be expelled from the university.
And so I spoke and they called me to the Dean of Men's office within a day or so. And the Dean of Men and Dean of Students talked to me and gave me a letter, expelled me from the university.
And simultaneously, with the time that they had me in this meeting, the president of the university had called a campus-wide assembly of students in the gymnasium and announced that because of the ongoing protest that he was going to close the school.
And that all students had to be off campus by 5 o'clock. This was a new new rally.
And so you've got students there from all over the state of Louisiana who don't know how to get back home. They've got to make combinations, got to get money, they got to contact their parents. And it was hectic and very scary to many of these students.
I didn't know quite what was going on because as I said, they had me in the Dean of Students office. They had it made this letter and it said that my connection with the university was being handed.
They said, I violated rule 18. And it was a rule in the university handbook that was entitled, lack of university adjustment.
And the rule read that the university reserves the right to sever a student's connection for general inability to adjust to the patterns of the institution period.
And however they interpret that.
Well, as I was told that this was a rule that they were using when students were homosexuals to expel them. But most of the students who had been in the movement, you see, they were expelled from them because they'd been arrested. Well, I hadn't been arrested at that time.
And so the only rule that they could find that they could use to justify my expulsion was this rule 18.
And so with that expulsion, actually I did not leave campus that night. I stayed in my dorm because a lot of the students actually couldn't literally get off campus at night, but the campus was on lockdown.
And we soon thereafter had to move off campus into a black hotel in downtown Baton Rouge and were banned from coming to the university campus.
So that must have sewn all sorts of, I mean, you talk about the chaos of everyone having to leave, but then that's so sort of recrimination, I would think among the students too.
Yes.
And there was confusion because when President Clark announced that the school was closing, he told the students we don't know when the school is going to reopen.
And we'll send you if you're to come back, we'll send you a letter. If you don't get a letter, don't come.
And so it wasn't just in a matter of those students because some other students, those who had been arrested and a handful of other leaders were explicitly told that they were expelled.
But many students were not told that they were expelled. They just did not get a letter to come back to the university. It opened about two weeks after Dr. Clark called. I think it was about 10 days that he reopened the university.
And in the meantime, we were trying to keep the boycott going and trying to get kids. And three of us who had been expelled took a taxi from downtown back to the campus to make a stand by attempting to register.
And the police quickly surrounded us on the campus. And fortunately for us, one of the university's security put us in a car and drove us to the edge of campus as we were followed by Louisiana Troopers.
Otherwise, we had been arrested on the campus, but they didn't want us to be arrested at that time, so they drove us off the campus.
But that was how determined they were to quell any continuing protests. And they did. They killed the movement. At least they killed it for time.
There. Yeah.
Now, how devoted were you to the concept of nonviolence in your protest there and did you ever think about other options, other ways of protesting?
We really, it really wasn't a choice. To me, the whole concept of nonviolence was for us really more of an academic issue because strategically you didn't have much choice but to be nonviolent.
I mean, if you're going into a lunch counter or as we were, three thousand of us marching from the campus to downtown Baton Rouge and they've got police dogs and they've got tear gas.
It didn't make any sense to be violent. How you got to fight back with something like that? All you could to.
So yes, we were strategically, we were all well dressed, orderly. And even as we ran with the gas and with the dogs, we tried to maintain some decor among ourselves.
But I would go as I said periodically down. In fact, I was, I was hold up in this black hotel in downtown Baton Rouge where we stayed for, oh, I'd guess, three, four weeks trying to carry our movement on and our bill was being paid by the National Office of Coa.
And so, SNCC, Student and Monocording Committee, one of the leaders that had gotten us stirred up in this second wave of protest was a young man by the name of Dion Diamond who had come to Baton Rouge, but Dion was a SNCC organizer that came to the Southern campus.
Now, there were organizers from New Orleans who had been with the Congress of Racial Equality who also involved. Well, Dion was arrested quickly for his coming on the campus, speaking and raising help.
So because Dion was in jail, we were out of school, we were down at the black hotel, a SNCC sent in to Baton Rouge to his field secretaries, Chuck McDew and Chuck McDew.
And well, Bob, I had known from, we were both at the Seminole at the University of Wisconsin the year before. And so, they came and checked in at the Lincoln Hotel where we were and they were going to visit Dion at the jail.
And they went down to see Dion and they were arrested. They looked into Bob and Chuck's precades and found some literature and stuff and accused him of criminal anarchy and sedition and arrested them.
And so, because of that involvement of the SNCC leaders, I then started going to Atlanta for some of the SNCC staff meetings.
And that's how I initially got to know John Lewis and Julian Bond, Julian was editing the SNCC newsletter, the student voice, and John was active in SNCC and Jim Foreman was the national director.
And so, I went to a couple of the SNCC meetings in Atlanta from Baton Rouge and some of the core people, Dave Dennis being one of them who was a core field secretary who was staying with us at the hotel but hadn't been a student.
And they were suspicious of what I was doing going to Atlanta meeting with the SNCC people. And I had a joint core. We created our own student organization called Student Action Committee, I think, because I just didn't want to be identified with a formal group.
And so, at one point they even looked at my mail that was coming from SNCC to see what kind of correspondence was going on.
Now, I mentioned that as an aside only to suggest that there were some rivalries. Now, I wasn't part of those rivalries because there was nothing sinister of one group plotting against the other but there was just that sort of group, I guess, self-protectiveness of turf, I guess, or whatever you want to call it.
And I was not a part of that. But by doing that, by getting to know some of the SNCC people, it expanded my base of contact with the movement because by the time I left Southern and went to school in Massachusetts, the Northern Student Movement, which was run by Peter Countryman, a young white student up in Yale, had been formed by Peter and some of his people, Thomas K. Gilhool and some others.
It was based there, and so I would go over from Worcester to Yale to some of the Northern Student Movement meetings. Well, because Northern Student Movement was so closely aligned as a support group in the North for SNCC, then the SNCC leaders would come up to the Yale campus for some meetings. And so I would go over to the New Haven. In fact, I started a chapter of the Northern Student Movement in Worcester.
And we started to do it in Worcester. And we started to do it in and having some anti-discrimination demonstrations against some businesses in Worcester.
Now, how did you end up at Clark?
Rather by circumstance, I guess after I was expelled from Southern, I was at the Lincoln Hotel.
We filed a lawsuit to try to get back in. We sued in federal court with lawyers from COA, law firm out of New Orleans, Collins Douglas in Eli, which was a black law firm that was helping us.
And they made a compromise with the university that they would let most of the students that had been expelled back. There were two of us that they would not take back.
And that was me and Ronnie Moore, who was one of the other student leaders.
And I was told that the president was mad at me because I had called up to his house one day when we were a group of us student protesters wanted to meet him, meet with him.
And I couldn't get him on the phone. And I think I might have spoken to Mrs. Clark. And I said, I mean, I'm not sure. But I said, if he won't meet with, we'll just come up there to the house.
And so it may have been his office. I'm not sure. But in any event, I'm told that he was angry about my rudeness in that encounter because I remember that we ended up marching to his house.
That was a little bit later, I think, because we had an all night vigil on his lawn. But this was also before we had been expelled. So Dr. Clark apparently was pretty clear that he didn't want me back.
So they settled the lawsuit and it didn't bother me that they settled it and said that why would it come back because maybe by that time I already had to offer to go to clock. I'm not sure.
That came because Walter Williams, who was a black student at Jackson State in Mississippi, was in the seminar with me at the university was constant the previous summer.
And so Walter had been offered a scholarship to go to clock because he'd been expelled as student by the president at Jackson State. And he said, well, I'm going to go into military, but contact my friend, D'Army Bailey and Baton Rouge.
He's been kicked out of school there. So they contacted me while I was at the hotel there in Baton Rouge and offered me a scholarship to go to clock. I didn't know anything about the university. Never heard of it.
And so I looked at the catalog and saw these white kids and this completed alien look of environment to me.
But you know, it was a, I could tell it was a good school and I didn't have one in any other school.
Right. And so I came back to Memphis and then I had to take the SAT test here in order to, I mean, I'd been admitted to clock, but I had to take the SAT.
And then last I went to, what is now Rhodes College, which is just a block away. And I took that that summer before I went to clock. I mentioned that because at the lunch break, the test administrators came over to me and pulled me aside and they said that I couldn't have lunch with the rest of the students who would take the test.
So two or three of them, very nicely, I mean, they were nice about it, but they took me into the faculty dining hall on the side and I had dinner with lunch with a couple of them because I couldn't with the, and this was in 1962.
But I took the SAT and then at fall, I went on to clock. Well, how did it, how did it come about was that a number of student leaders in the South were being expelled.
And so this was a gesture made on the led by students at clock University to raise money and they had car washes and bake sales and the like and they raised a couple of thousand dollars in the University made a chip in a little bit and offered a scholarship to some students who had been expelled from the Southern School.
And consequently, that's how I ended up there.
Was there other schools that were doing some more things? I've never heard of that. How's that happening?
I don't know. I do know that Senator Jabbits made note of the clock effort in the Senate records there because it was announced in just your own there part at the time.
So you, and as you mentioned, it was a bit of a different world that you entered into in Worcester coming from Tennessee and also Louisiana.
I didn't know really what to expect. I mean, I knew I had a free train ride because my father could get the pass to ride up to Massachusetts. I'd have to go all the way up through upstate New York because I had to follow the route that Illinois Central had partnership with New York Central.
And so I would go to Chicago and then Chicago up through Pekipsi and Buffalo and all those places to ultimately get to Boston. Well, actually to Wister.
And when I got there, the school had picked out two nice students to Bob.
I have trouble with him in his last name. I think it was Miller and Fred Jealous and they met at the train station.
They had an apartment that I was to share with him. And so they took me over. Fred, by coincidence, is the father of Ben Jellis now the national head of the NA.
But I was I room with them for the first year that I was there in the apartment, which was right in a building owned by the university.
And could you have lived on campus? Was that an option? Yes, it was, I think.
But I think the university was wanting to create an environment for me with two, I guess, volunteers or nice students, nice little, I mean, what?
Fans, they've had a nice apartment. So it never came up. I mean, they had placed for me when I got there.
So I just went and I remember my 21st birthday party. They gave me a fifth of Jack Daniels.
You know, so they were nice. When I first got to clock, students were, of course, I was something of a cost of labor because I was the one that they had raised the money to bring up there.
And kids would want to talk to me about the South. And initially I would talk to them about the South and Civil Rights and the like.
And then I got tired of it. I got tired of just talking about race in the South. And I started asking them about what was going on in Worcester.
Well Worcester didn't have a large black community. It was only about 3,000 out of like a couple hundred thousand people.
But that black community that they had was in a segregated area of the city. And there was not much interaction of that community with the rest of the community as I said.
Departments to a downtown didn't have any black clerks. The big factory there, Wyman-Gordon, which was run by National Secretary of the John Burst Society, had 18 black employees and they were all janitors.
So I started, so I went over to the Yale campus and getting support to start this Worcester student movement, this WSM chapter on the clock campus.
I drew in students, liberal white students from the campus, as well as a handful of people from the black community in Worcester.
And we formed a group and started having meetings. We began tutoring the main mission of Northern Student Movement, part of this mission was to tutor kids and intercity neighborhoods.
And so we had volunteers that were tutoring those kids. How about if it in Worcester was created an organization called Prospect House, which is now an ongoing community institution of some importance to Worcester.
Abbie Hoffman was living in Worcester at the time and had come out of Brandeis and needed a cause and he attached himself to our efforts.
Even though he was a student, but he was living there and he became sort of self-appointed publicist for us, putting out a newsletter called The Drum.
And we came by meetings. But we were primarily students and members of the Worcester black community.
And we set about the business of finding out what was happening on the job front with the Noides.
And we did tackle the largest industrial employer in Worcester, Wyman Gordon company, which was, say, was run by Robert W. Stoddard, who was the national secretary of John Birch, society.
We met with him and asked him about his employment of blacks and whether he would promote him.
And he said that in essence, no. And so we picketed his plant, brought the plant to a stop at least for one day because the teamsters wouldn't cross our picket line.
And I filed complaints with the Massachusetts commission against discrimination and the defense department because they were a big defense contractor.
And investigations were undertaken by both agencies in which they found some cause and demanded to a required that the plant undergo some change.
So this was a case of not only where we put in pressure, starting as just a group of young activists, but we were putting pressure on this big factory.
And Stoddert was not just a owner of Wyman Gordon, he also owned the Worcester Telegram in Gazette, which was the local newspaper and radio station at WTAG.
And was on the board of clock.
It's in a lot of power.
Yes, but clearly.
In fact, the president of clock called me in just a day of our picket and was gently trying to dissuade us. He wasn't heavy handed about it.
But by that time, when I called over to the picket line, they already started.
And so I had a good out with Dr. Jefferson that I couldn't stop it because it was already started.
But we, I mentioned the multifaceted strategy, picketing, but also those complaints with the Massachusetts Commission and with the defense department.
So here we were using multifaceted strength against this corporation and made them change.
And it was clear to me that you can as a small force.
But if you use the right strategies and do your research and know where the vulnerabilities are, you can force corporations to change.
And that's what we did in Worcester.
When I graduated, there was an editorial in the student newspaper that said, one is enough.
And the editor was talking about that some students had talked about having another campaign to raise funds to bring a student from the south.
And they said, we've had that experience once before and he found racial problems under every rock, so to speak.
And we don't need to do that again.
And the next issue of the clock paper, though, was had a page full of letters in opposition and in support of that I wasn't really that terrible for us on the clock campus.
Clock gave me an honorary doctorate of laws three years ago.
Now, you know, this is okay.
I'm curious about, you know, we're now in the north and it's a couple of years later, you had been talking about the sort of the very real sort of fear and intimidation that was so prevalent in the south when you first went down to southern.
Well, was the situation like that you found a few years later in up north around the park and in Worcester.
And what gave you the strength to do things like challenge the national director or the town versus I?
I didn't have much fear in Worcester.
And the position to what we were doing was there wasn't any visible.
There were some students actually from the clock campus who counterpicked it against us when we picketed the plant.
But the police in charge, Sergeant, at the scene of our protest came over to me because they had wanted some of our students to let the trucks come through.
And the police refused to cross the line, but there were some company on trucks that wanted to come on into the plant.
And some of the students had taken the part themselves to decide that they would continue to circle in the driveway and not let the trucks through.
And so the police in charge came over to me and he said, look, I don't like this some bitch anymore you do.
But you can't continue to block this driveway.
It was none union.
But you're going to have to do something here.
And so I spoke to the kids and I told them I said, look, they said you're going to have to stop and let these trucks in.
Oh, you're going to be arrested now.
I'll leave it up to you all.
Even though I was there as part of them, but I was addressing them as positive policemen.
And I said, now if you stay, I'll join you.
But if you want to leave, then now is the time to let these trucks through.
And by this time, one of the priests, there was one of our supporters in a bean and pleaded with us yet again to let the trucks through Father Bernard Gilgun, Father Bernard Gilgun, who was an activist priest and wister.
And so we then relented and that the trucks come through.
But I'm saying that started was at least not just for the reasons of our civil rights protest, but because of the union issue.
There were also some people that were supportive of what we were doing.
But the opposition in the northeast was much more refined.
The Wuster Area Council of Churches invited started to speak at a luncheon at their meeting.
And we contacted them and said, well, let us come and give us that.
This was in the wake of our picket and the plant.
And they refused.
And so we picketed the Wister Area Council of Churches, luncheon.
And so it was really the quiet opposition that you had to deal with.
We didn't have people threatening us on the sidewalks.
One of the black ministers who was ahead at NACP and Wister Rubenstringfield criticized us picketing and said that we were going off half cocked when we picketed first the downtown department store.
And so what we did was a number of us increased the membership of the NA with young people, students, from the campus and some people in black community.
Then I called Rubenstringfield to the side and I said, look, we're going to picket the plant.
And I want you to join us on the picket line.
And I said, in essence, if you don't, we're going to move to vote you out at the end of the ACP.
And so he resigned and we had an organization.
But the result was that we were moving to preempt an attack from the NAACP, which we'd seen happen in our first picket.
And so again, it was a matter of using strategy and from without going within the NAACP to boost the membership and therefore give ourselves a position of strength.
Now when I was in Wister, now when I brought Malcolm X to speak, I had called Malcolm at his home in New York and asked if he would come and speak on the campus, which he agreed to do.
And then a couple of the members of the board of our organization, White Minister said they would quit the organization unless we got someone to give the other point of view.
And so when I told that back to Malcolm by phone and I had gotten him on the phone at his home, it was amazing that I was able to do it.
But I did and I told him that they said that I'd have to have someone present to have the point of view and he said, well, I'll debate Talk to King.
And so I said, well, all right, let me see what I can do. I called Atlanta and asked him if Dr. King would debate Malcolm and they said, no, he's not available, but the buy at Westernwood.
And so when I talked back to Malcolm, he sort of chuckled on the phone and he said he knew that King wouldn't debate him, but he wasn't going to debate by Western.
And so with that, I decided that if those ministers were going to quit, they were just going to have to quit because we were just going to go ahead and bring Malcolm to speak in Western, which we did.
Did he say why he didn't want to debate Western?
He thought Western was just a lackey for a front for King. He wanted to debate into King.
So that was the debate he wanted. He wasn't going to debate some second. I mean, Western wasn't true. I mean, he's credited with being the leading star behind the scenes of the marginal life done.
But that would have been a heck of a debate too, I think.
In what? But Malcolm was going to have no part of that.
So he came and I spent the day with him and he was just an extraordinary person. I went with him to the radio station, the front interview, started some station because of WTAG, but Julie Chase Fuller, who was one of the disc talkies there, conducted the interview.
She was very supportive of what we were doing in the Worcester. She and I and Malcolm were at the interview together. I did mostly listening.
It was mostly between her and Malcolm. There were a couple of times during the interview when I was kind of asked whether I agreed with Malcolm and I was careful not to get drawn into a May versus Malcolm X debate.
Because I tended to agree with a lot of what Malcolm was saying. Now, of course, Malcolm, as you know, was not in favor of nonviolence and he made that very clear.
But I was never an advocate of nonviolence as a belief, as I said earlier. We were forced into nonviolence by the reality of the circumstances.
When I went from New Orleans to Bolulusa, with these two priests in the summer, let's say I was working in that summer in New Orleans and we went over and that would have been in the summer of 65.
We were going to participate in a protest in Bolulusa. We got met on the other end of the Lake Puncher Train Bridge by armed colload of people with the Deacon's Foot of Fence and Justice.
They followed us in the town, put us up in a house where they kept watch. Then at the rally, the march that we went to, they had people carrying shotguns alongside the march.
And that didn't bother me in the least bit. I was rather reassured because the Deacon's philosophy was that we were going to fight back.
In fact, and I don't know how historically accurate this is, but there was some scuttle butt that some whites had run through the black community attempted to intimidate them with some gunfire and that the Deacon's had fired back and wounded someone.
But that it had been downplayed because they did not want that publicly known.
So to me, now the kind of violence that I would have been against, however, would have been random violence. I mean self-defense was one thing.
But proactive violence, for example, with the weatherman and others were doing fireball guns and that kind of thing.
I would not have necessarily hourly condemned it to those who believed so firmly in their cause that they chose to resort to that.
But I would not have been a part of it. But I can accept that some people would feel so strongly of the need for change and that other means that fail, that they would have to make some, take some acts of violence.
And particularly, and I think for black people in general, I did not think that was particularly effective and defensible strategy.
Did you involved with the Hicks family? Did they need me to interview the Hicks family in both of us?
Hicks, yes. I thought you said hooks. I said, okay, Hicks, yes. In fact, I think I met some of them then when I was over there.
Well, also that same summer that I went over for that march, I had actually, I was, what I was doing was, I was in my second year of law school, I believe, between the first and second year.
And I was working actually out of the office of Ernest "Dutch" Morial, who was practicing law at the time, along with AP to roll.
Ernest, who, I'm sorry?
Ernest "Dutch" Morial.
Moriel.
Yeah. And he was one of, again, one of the black lawyers doing some work. He'd given me office space in his office in New Orleans.
He later became mayor of New Orleans. And his son is actually now the national head of the Urban League, Marc Morial.
But the reason I was in New Orleans at summer is summer of 65.
Would you mind just waiting until the phone?
No. Answer.
Okay. Great. Sorry about that.
When I was in New Orleans in the summer of 65, I was in between my first and second year of law school.
And the NA Legal Offence Fund office in New York had hired a half dozen or so law students, mostly blacks.
And they sent one of us each to a Southern state. That was the year that Title VII had become effective.
It had been passed in 64, but you could begin to file complaints in 65.
And so the Legal Offence Fund sent us out to employees to file Title VII complaints.
And so I had gone over to Boelusa, even prior to that first march.
And I had gotten workers at the Crown Zellabog plant in Boelusa to file Title VII complaints.
In fact, those were some of the first complaints and most effective complaints under Title VII.
But that was the work that I was doing with the Legal Offence Fund that summer.
Okay. All right.
And then you finished law school at Yale?
Yeah. At that time I had done a year's law study at Boston University.
And while there I'd gotten involved with a group called Law Students Civil Rights Research Council, this week.
And it had been formed by some Northeastern law students.
It was founded by private foundations, New York, Fawn, the Taconic Foundation, Rockefeller Brothers Fund, New York foundations, some others.
And the idea with the LSCRRC Law Student Civil Rights Research Council was that the lawyers in the South who were doing civil rights work was overwhelmed that they needed help.
And the best way to help them was to take some of the top law students from universities around the country and send them to the South.
And so we had funding to hire these law students in the summer and send them to all the South.
We would hire about anywhere from 200 to 200 law students, pay them 30 dollars a week, which was just enough for them to pay for their food and laundry.
And we'd put them out in a black community.
And they would stay with people in the community.
And the lawyers would typically help find a place for them to stay while they were assigned to the lawyers' offices.
And they'd work there.
It was a twofold strategy with LSCRRC.
The first part of it was to provide this much needed help to these lawyers.
We didn't confine ourselves to the South, but I'd say 90% of our students were in the South.
But we also put lawyers in simple limitedties offices outside of the South to work with ACLU people.
In fact, the headquarters for the organization was in the National Office of the ACLU.
Oh, it was, okay.
And so my first year of law study at Boston University, I organized a chapter of this organization at Boston University.
And so that summer was when I did the work with Legal Defense Fund.
Was that an assignment from this organization?
No, it was separate.
It was separate.
And then I got accepted into Yale as a transfer student.
And so instead of returning to BU, I went to New Haven.
I actually had applied while I was at clock to Yale in Columbia and Hobbit and several other schools
and had been rejected by all of them.
I'd been accepted at Boston University.
I was on my way back to a clock one day with one of my schoolmates back home.
And I asked him to stop at Yale and we stopped over on the campus.
And I went to the Dean of Admissions Office.
And it turned out to be a one-on-white man, of course, all of the top people there are white.
From ball of attenuation about 80 miles up the road from Memphis.
And Dean Tate, Jack B. Tate, and we got to talking and he took a like and to men.
We talked a little bit about my civil rights background.
And he said, well, let me see if there's someone around still that I can introduce you to.
None of the people keep people on the campus at the time.
So he said, well, you go on back and let me see what I can do.
So the end result was he got me on a waiting list, but they never had the openings.
And so he said, you go on the New Year first year and then get in touch with me.
And so it was that summer while I was working out of Murray Hill's office
that Dean Tate sent me all that in and said, I could come to Yale as a transfer.
So if you hadn't just stopped over on the campus, I never would have.
That would have happened.
That's amazing.
That already been rejected.
That's a great story.
Okay. So just I guess continuing with the chronology that you after you graduate from
well school at Yale.
And following law school, I was the second summer after I had done that summer in New Orleans.
I worked out of New York traveling around the South to coordinate these law students.
And so I had developed a pretty good friendship with many of the leaders on different campuses.
And we had campuses from California to New York.
And there were about 35 law schools, I remember the chapters of LSCRRC.
And so I was elected to National Director.
The National Director would serve for each year they pick a new National Director.
And that would be someone who would just finish law school.
And so I went from law school to the headquarters, which was, as I say, in the National Office of the ACLU.
In New York.
And so that's what I did in my first year at a law school.
And interestingly, Bill Robinson, who was the director before me, had gotten a deferment.
Because by this time the draft was very alive and active.
And I was prime candidate in terms of my age and being single.
And we drafted.
That had nothing to do quite honestly with the work that I was doing with LSCRRC.
But Robinson had gotten the draft deferment working with the organization.
And so I applied for a deferment as well when I went to work with LSCRRC.
And I had letters from Jack Pemberton.
And I think Robert L. Carter even, I just sent a letter for me.
I had had some key national, civil rights people to write letters saying that this work that I was doing was in the National interest.
So I came down to Memphis and I met with a draft board.
We had one black on the draft board.
My brother had talked with him.
And he was very supportive.
And I was thinking about four whites on the board.
And I came down and talked with him.
Well, one of the white ladies, when I got into the meeting with him, she was intrigued to know what I was,
what kind of work I was doing.
And we got to talk about civil rights.
Well, it turns out she had had a daughter who had been somewhat involved in civil rights activities in the North.
But the long story that story was that after a very cordial meeting, they gave me a deferment.
And this was in 1967 from a draft board here in Memphis that said that my work as a director in New York was in the National interest.
And therefore, they granted me a deferment.
And so, of course, that year's deferment actually got me past the age limit where I would have been drafted.
Because I was kind of torn really personally because if I had gotten drafted, I didn't quite know what I would have done.
I was pretty strong in my belief that the war was wrong.
And I don't think that I was prepared to put my life on the line and go to Vietnam on a war that I felt was wrong.
So, but I never had to come to really make those tough choices because I got the deferment.
But I think that I would have rather gone to jail than to have gone to Vietnam war.
Of course, this was 1967.
The height I would have been going to teach ends in Boston, starting Howard Zinn and others were speaking at these.
And making some very persuasive presentations about the wrong of the war.
And I was convinced that it was wrong.
And so, I was, Norman Thomas was one of the people that I brought to speak at the Clark campus as well.
I was still in Worcester.
So, anyway, I did the work there with the LSCRRC for that year.
In fact, I raised a special grant money and sent ten law students down here to work with the Lawyers doing a sanitation strike when they were on strike.
And the first suspect, Alex Hurder, I think, was his name.
He is now a law professor in Vanderbilt.
Alex Hurder, I think, is Herder.
But he was the first person taken into custody in Memphis as a suspect in the assassination because he was a white person down around the Lorraine Motel Motel at the time of the assassination.
Of course, he was released relatively soon afterwards.
But the night of the assassination, I was in my office.
I basically closed down. This was about six o'clock New Yorktown, which was closer to seven here.
And my secretary came out and told me that the radio had announced.
And she'd heard on the radio, Dr. King had been shot.
And then a minute later, she came back out and said that he was dead.
And what I was working late that night because I was getting my... I had a flight to Memphis schedule for the next day because there was going to be a march that Dr. King was to lead within three or four days.
I think April the 8th.
So of course, New York was tense and on the edge that night.
And I did take a plane the next day and come to Memphis.
And then I went on from Memphis to Atlanta where they had his funeral services, but I couldn't get into him.
And I didn't even need him because it was packed so I stood up.
I hadn't been went over to the Morehouse campus where they had a caravan from the church.
And I think they brought his body over there and they had speakers and things at the Morehouse campus.
Well, but following my work with the Law Students Council in New York, which ended in 68, then I had to decide...
I had office to stay in New York and work either at NYU Law School or with some foundations.
And I had an offer to go out to work with Cummins Engine Foundation.
Philip Sorensen and had made me...
and offered me a position with the foundation out there.
But I had been out to California because we had chapters at UC Hastings College of the Law and at Boalt Hall and at UCLA.
When I was in the Bay Area there, visiting the chapters during that year that I was running the organization, I had a great time and it was such a beautiful area.
And one of the former presidents or directors of my group was then working with legal services in San Francisco, Steve Antler.
And so he persuaded the director out there to offer me a job on the staff of legal services in San Francisco.
What's the last name, Steve?
Antler, ATL and TLER.
And so I chose to move out to San Francisco in the winter of 68.
I actually took a two months and went to Europe by myself with a book called,
You Up on 5 Dolls a Day.
Remember that?
It worked sometimes.
I, on two or three occasions, was lucky enough to meet somebody who would take me in and that kind of helped me part of the way that while I was staying around over in Europe.
But then I came out to California and that was about October and November of 68.
I started practicing law in San Francisco and continued to do that with legal services.
I was in the Central Office doing test case litigation, primarily on areas of consumer fraud.
And I became outspoken among the, we had Central Office and then there were neighborhood offices, two of which were run by black lawyers.
And you know, you have to always leave your own motives up for examination whether by others or by yourself.
And when I had taken that job, I thought that I had kind of reached an understanding with the director that I'd be able to do some other things.
But I think that part of it is, I'm not well fit to work for people, I don't think, to be on a job.
I mean, I started asking questions and I started challenging the authority of the leadership and talking about the fairness with which other employees were being treated in the Central Office and then the neighborhoods.
And it led to some polarization within the offices, particularly in the Central Office, to the point that I went to the board meeting and said that the director ought to be lying, which he did.
And he said that they had a black guy that came in and he fired me within.
Very short time after.
And I filed a lawsuit on the lawyers, white lawyer on the staff who was one of my supporters filed a suit for me in federal court.
I didn't think including the lawyers would be treated with the same degree of fairness that others were.
And they agreed, I mean, the ethnic and black lawyers agreed with me, but they as often happens, people don't speak up.
They support you and they'll tell you quietly how much they agree with you.
But you get left out there on that lamb, you know.
You want to go battle with you.
And of course, that's part of it.
If you and I were willing to be on that limb by yourself, then you better stay at home because that's going to happen time and again.
So you found yourself on that limb a few times in your life?
But I've been blessed that when I fall on the limb, there's always another net somewhere.
And another one.
It's a compliment.
Because while I was with legal services in San Francisco, a young white fellow came to me and volunteered and confessed to his wife had a lot of money.
And he didn't know what to do with it. He felt guilty about it.
And after he turned down my initial suggestion that they could give me a million dollars, which I actually didn't tell him.
And he looked at me seriously and said, well, he would think about it.
And he went and talked with his life about it.
And the reason I said that was because you can't make change without money.
I mean, whether it's in civil rights or any other kind of struggle, it takes money. It took money in the movement.
It took money with our lost students.
I was going to mention this when you talked about the foundations that supported your lost student organization.
Because to me, that is one of the great untold stories of the civil rights movement at that time was the Rockefeller Foundation support, the conic, the movement couldn't have survived without those.
And when those foundations did disappear or stopped giving money, it really changed the world.
Absolutely. And what happened was that Congress saw the impact that these foundations was having.
And they then attacked these foundations and intimidated them one after another.
And backed them off.
Because I mean, one of the, I mean, Leslie W. Dunbar, who let the field foundation.
You know, he was one of the, I mean, Marian Wright Edelman, he got Marian Wright Edelman to start it and build in the Children's Defense Fund.
He was close to, he got John Lewis. In fact, it came to the, when Vernon E. Jordan Jr had hit it, the Voter Education Project in Atlanta for the Southern Regional Council.
When Vernon left that, it came down to whether they were going to have me or John Lewis.
When I said they, Leslie W. Dunbar was really the person who was talking to both of us about taking that position as the head of the Voter Education Project, Voter Education Project.
And Leslie, he said, well, look, he said, John can use this position at this time much more than the news.
In essence, what he is, how he kind of made the decision. It was two good men that he had to do it. And he picked John.
But when I was in San Francisco, I was, he hired me as a consultant to the field foundations.
So I would go back and meet with the board, which was chaired by Ruth Field.
But if you want it, I organized while I was on the City Council in Berkeley, California.
And two black kids got killed on the campus of Southern in a protest demonstration.
And that was, I think, around 1972, everyone's 72.
And the media was unclear about how they got killed or who killed them, or they'd been killed by Sheriff's Deputy on the campus.
And then a lion of sheriff's deputy started firing at the students and two of them ended up dead.
And they said, they never knew who did it.
And so I called black lawyer that I knew in Baton Rouge. He said, well, you could help if you came down.
And I called Les Dunbar in New York. And I said, Les, I said, I'd like to go down to Baton Rouge.
And so he said, well, all right. So he gave me $5,000 of money from Field Foundation.
And he contacted John Lewis and Owusu Sadaukai, who was the leader of a black nationalist group.
And my brother out of Memphis took another black councilman with me from Berkeley, California.
And we, W. Haywood Burns, who was head in the National Conference of Black Lawyers.
And we went down to Baton Rouge and convened what we call the black people's community inquiry into the shooting depths of these students.
And we had hearings. And then actually the governor came to the hearing to come and have it.
But we focused attention and got the story out. But I mentioned that because I would not have been able to do that.
If I hadn't been able to pick up phone call Les Dunbar, I'd get that $5,000 from them.
They would be ten. But because actually when I left California, he gave me $5,000 to help me relocate from California.
So he was helping out individual.
Yeah, I gave him a grant. He was to write a story on black lawyers in Tennessee.
So that was, yeah, it's a way of getting it done, getting you some money, sure.
But you see, if I went to him when I had a project, I could go to the Norman Foundation or the Vanguard Foundation that I think was a new world foundation,
or I'd have been less than done by it field. But Lesley could talk to the heads of the other foundations.
And then they would act as a consortium to put the money together to find it.
What was the first thing you said in the new world?
Debbie was with the Norman Foundation.
Norman Foundation. And there was Taconic Foundation. There was Rockefeller Brothers Fund. There was the New York Foundation.
Cummins Engine Foundation out of Indiana. Stern Family Fund out of New Orleans.
So these were all well known to people in the movement where they could get the money?
Absolutely.
Where money could be.
Exactly.
And it was the same group. Same group with foundations.
And without them, you know, much of this wouldn't have happened.
And they had the kind of relationship with leaders, including King and others.
Cesar Chavez, done by helped the United Farm Workers through the support that he could generate.
So, yes, these...
So my friends in San Francisco, they were...it was ironic because when my friend came to me and he said...
He said, you know...
You want me to stop for a second?
My friend came to me and said, you know, I told you earlier that I had some money, but it actually was quite a lot of money.
And we...I'd like your ideas what do it. And I said, well, give me a million dollars. The reason I said that was because...
I knew that my commitment would be to use that money to stir up things, to make things happen, to change things.
It wasn't just to go live constantly on a boat somewhere. But I would be free of strings if it was my money.
So he came back and said, well, we're not going to do that, but what we will do is we'll bring a million dollars from the Northeast out here to California,
and set up a trust and put you in charge of it. And then you can take the money.
He said that you can take all of the interest or dividends and earnings because they put it into an account at Bank of America,
which was in turn invested. And so you can take the dividend money and give it away heavy-wish.
And plus you can go into the corpus at least to a hundred thousand dollars without talking to us.
And they paid me ten thousand dollars salary to do this.
Now the purpose for them doing this, saying it up, was they said, we want you to give this money to projects that are not tax exempt,
that the ones that are now getting support from foundations and alike, those are not the ones we want to support.
We want to give it to non-taxative exempt organizations.
And so I was able to pick and choose different projects going on around the country.
And I did that. Of course, that was just a part-time position, but I also, as I said, was engaged as a consultant to field foundation at the same time.
And was a consultant with another group that was recruiting minority law students, Cleo, Councilor Legal Education,
and then I was recruiting Blackshin, I think I was name it.
Anyway, so with the funds, so after I had gotten fired at Legal Services, I was able to continue to float with the independent income I had coming in.
Well, I was living in Berkeley, California because...
I was a foundation ever, I have a name, or was that quiet?
Yes, we named it Bread Limited Trust.
Bread Limited Trust. Meaning we didn't have a whole lot of money.
I love it.
All right.
And so I was at the same time on the board of Berkeley, California Legal Services. In fact, at one point I became chairman of the board of Berkeley, California Legal Services.
And I became active in the Berkeley, California Black Caucus.
And so by the time Ron Dellums ran, he had been on the City Council and was very visible as a councilman out there.
And so because of Dellems' eloquent statements against war, he became very supported by the white left.
And so that's how he got to be elected Congress from there.
And so when Dellems got elected to the Congress, my friend Ira Simmons and I, who at Arrowwoods of Lawyer, that had come out West and was working up in Sacramento,
and I had encouraged him to come to Berkeley, California and helped him to get a post with the Berkeley, California Legal Services because I was on the board there.
Also a Black player.
And so he and I were spending the evening just relaxing at his home and we said, well, we ought to run for the council.
Because Dellems had gotten elected so there was a Vegas degree.
And so we said, well, we'll run a ticket of the team, two of us.
I didn't know anything about the politics in Berkeley, California.
This was just looking at what do we do next kind of thing.
And so it, but that choice, that decision we made came at the same time that the white left had been planning and organizing for a good while to run candidates in the Berkeley, California City elections.
And they had formed their group called the April Coalition.
And so the deal that they had set up was that the white left, the April Coalition would pick two candidates, two whites, and the Berkeley, California Black Caucus would pick two black candidates.
And those candidates would run as a slate to be endorsed by Ron Dellums.
And so by this time, Ira Simmons were regular attendees at the Berkeley, California Black Caucus meeting.
I had even given $500 or so of my friend's money to help them get a headquarters.
And so we were liked within the caucus and we announced that we were going to run for council.
And so they kind of got the caucus upset because they already had in mind who they were going to put onto the ticket in these two seats.
And so they kind of pleaded with Ira Simmons, not to run.
And Dellems pleaded with us.
And so when they saw that we were going to move forward, then the plea was, well, why don't one of you run?
And I said, no, that's not going to work because I didn't want to, if I showed that I was willing to dump Aaron,
because he didn't have the money, I had the money, then that was sort of weak in me at the beginning.
And might create an adversary that I didn't want.
So I said, no, we are, it's both of us or nothing.
So in the end, we forced the caucus to accept us as their two candidates because they knew that I had the money and that I was going to run.
I went to my friends and I said, look, I'm going to run for council.
I need you to put up the money. I need to use your money is what I said.
And they said, all right.
And so that's how I got to be, the two of us got on to the ticket with Loni Hancock and Rick Brown, who was the student.
And so the April coalition knew nothing about us.
We had had no dealings with them.
And I'm going to turn that off.
Okay, it's going.
Great. So just pick up where we had been talking about the formation of the April coalition.
You and I are, are, are, are, are put on the ticket?
Yes. And the thing about it was that this was my first foray into elected politics in Canada.
I never really seen myself as writing for office.
In fact, when I went to sign up as a candidate at City Hall, the City Court clerk asked me my voter registration and I wasn't registered.
And so I had to go register before I could sign up as a candidate.
I had not lived in Berkeley, California, but three months before the election election was April.
I moved from Kensington, California, which was a suburb, adjacent to Berkeley, California, into Berkeley, California 90 days before the election in order to qualify.
And so, and it never, to be quite candid, I'd never been to a council meeting, or even in the council chambers.
But as I said, Ira Simmons had made the decision that we were going to run.
We thought it would be a good form, which we've been there long enough to see the energy and the politics of the area.
And so we thought we could introduce some new thought.
And so, when I had my announcement, I made a statement.
And I don't think that people were paying much attention because again, we were very new.
But I said that my first priority is going to be to the interest of the black community.
And that was pure Southern.
That was that was Deami Bailey speaking from in the context of my experience and politics here in the South, where if you're a black politician, then you're...
That was what you were about.
You were about speaking for one advance interest of blacks.
And so, I did not see that as being necessarily much different from what my agenda should and would be in Northern California.
Because I knew that the interest of whites, I could look at the platform and the work that was being done.
Well, also knew that we would look upon with suspicion about a black Indigenous black community there, because they were not that supportive of the white left.
They always had questions about the motives and even though the Panthers were close with the white left.
And there was support for the Panthers, but there was some suspicion or discomfort there too.
So here we are in new commerce.
And we had to establish our own sense of legitimacy first with a base.
That would be the black community.
And in fact, the April coalition wanted us to run a joint campaign office.
I said, no, so we'll open our own office in the black community.
And we're not going to start carrying your two candidates with us into the community to campaign.
And so we've got not there and introduced ourselves.
And then we'll bring you in.
And so, early on in the campaign, we were offering some feathers in terms of the position we had already ruffled the feathers of the caucus.
We had put delums in a fix in terms of having to endorse us.
And one of the people that he wanted to run was his good friend, Ken Simmons, who was going to be one of the two.
That was already supposed to fill those seats.
And so by the time we won the election, and we had started working with the, bringing the white candidates into the black community.
But by this time, we were pretty strong forces in our own right as politicians having to run a very strong campaign.
And I brought in merely everyone who walked the streets of Berkeley, California with us to help us campaign.
I had Julian Bond, who cut a radio spot for me.
And we had a damn good campaign manager that we had.
We had two initially that were not that good.
And we ended up with one who knew what he was doing, Boulsettner, who had campaigned with Birch Bayh out in Indiana.
He was a lost student of that time at Boulte.
And so came election day, we were on a roll.
We had some friction.
There were points in which the coalition was about to fall apart because of our determination to set our own agenda.
But we held together and then came election.
And we had two of the three seats, Loni Hancock, who won the other one.
And they're fourth kind of, they lost.
And so we came in too strong to one strong on the white left, at least the far white left.
Because Berkeley, California's left was not all homogeneous.
I mean, one of my strongest supporters then, and throughout was Dan Siegel, who had been the president of the student body.
And luckily, who sort of was speaking on the campus when he said, let's go down and retake the park.
And that's what led to a deadly confrontation down until our pavingew about the demonstrations against people's park.
So I had to support.
And then I had some run-ins with the Panthers, but Huey Newton.
Huey Newton the Panthers.
Again, I'm not a joiner.
I tried to make that as diplomatically clear to here as I could that I would support his programs.
He said, you know, you come and put your office in hours, we'll feature you in our Black Panther newspaper.
And I begged off from that, well, I would go to here his penthouse at 12, when you'd make sure to drive our,
and I would meet with him and talk with him time to time.
And I had some Chivas Regal and have an enjoyable visit.
But he then asked me for money, asked me for $25,000, and I told him that I didn't have it.
And from that point, he began to become threatening and I had to stop visiting with Huey.
But I continued to support on the council the programs that the Panthers were pushing, the Free Breakfast Program.
We found it some of their daycare programs and other things.
The Conservatives who had initially said they were going to recall all three of us said then that, well,
let's not recall a lighty handcock, she's not a big problem, that barely is the problem.
But they wanted to get both me and Irish Simmons, my colleague.
But then Wilmot Sweeney, who was a conservative Black Council member, the first Black Councilman,
and Berkeley, California said, well, you can't do that if you're going to drop off the White Woman on here,
then you can't just run a recall against two Blacks.
And so at that point, they said, well, let's drop Irish Simmons.
And so I was then the one they chose to focus in on because they had figured,
and I think correctly so that if they could get me, then they succeeded in that,
that they would be able to stop the force of what we were doing, which was using the council chamber
as a megaphone to demand change and get change.
Philibust in the meeting? Yes, I did.
I would talk in the council meetings at some times to the point that the mayor, who was Black,
which said, well, Mr. Bill, you out of order.
And I would keep talking and he would ask the clerk to turn my microphone off,
and I would stand and continue to talk.
And of course, we had a crowd, typically the meetings were crowded with people.
And we had issues that we were fighting, and I had a staff, because I had taken,
not only when I found my campaign accounts showing that I'd spent $25,000 in the campaign,
and I listed 25 as being anonymous, which you could do in California at the time.
And that raised a lot of our roles, and where's the money coming from?
So not only was I then being accused of being a COVID-bagger,
because that was one of the things that conservative views against me.
But then, of course, it wasn't, where's he getting this funding from?
Well, the agreement that I had made with my friends was that I was not going to put their name out in public.
I mean, they were two quiet people, young people, and they did not want the notoriety.
In fact, Mike Wallace interviewed me on 60 minutes, and asked me, well, where's your money coming from?
And I was a bit surprised, because he had been very charming.
We met on the campus of UC Berkeley, California, and then we'd driven over to my,
I had a little cottage right near the Berkeley, California Hills, and we sat out on the patio,
and as soon as the camera started rolling, he became quite a different person.
And went after me, and he wanted to know where was the money coming from,
and I was a little surprised by that.
And I said, well, I'm not going to tell you.
So, what are you living up here in a nice place, and you're driving a nice car,
and people have a right to know.
I said, well, the less you know about me, the stronger I am, I'm not going to let people know everything about me.
And I felt that way that, that if you know the source of my support, then you know where you can make your attack.
And so I didn't tell him, well, this aired actually on 60 minutes, this segment.
But before he aired it, he called me from New York, and he said,
Deami, I'm putting this show together, and I'm going to give you one last opportunity to tell me where your money's coming from.
And I said, well, I'm sorry, I'm not going to tell you.
He said, well, if you don't tell us, we're going to find out anyway.
And I said, well, you mean he said, well, there's a group that's put up some funds to find out where your money's coming from.
So, I called Leslie W. Dunbar after that back in New York, and I said, less, I said, Mike Wallace tells me that somebody has put up money in fact, I wear my money's coming from him.
And he said, well, let me look into it.
And so he called me back, and he said, sure enough, there was a group called the Fund for Investigative Journalism,
and that they had gotten a grant from the Stern family, I don't know all of this, too.
And I wear my money's coming from him.
Now, this continued to be a so-and-so point in Berkeley, California, and it was kind of dogged at my heels, because I wouldn't tell who this was.
At one point, there was a counterintelligence black spy for the government, for California, who actually revealed himself as such.
He would go into radical organization and stir up dissent and distrust, and he had infiltrated my campaign.
And he wrote about it in a book, the Glass House tapes.
But at one point, he went on radio in Los Angeles and said he had given me $10,000 to help him infiltrate the Angela Davis campaign.
And I had to then go to KPFA, the sister station in Berkeley, California.
And he was on the microphone in Los Angeles, where he was making this out of land discharge.
And I told him, told the station there that you've been in Berskate this before you run it.
Well, clearly what he was trying to do was smoke me out.
He knew that I couldn't reveal my financial solicits, and he was trying to discredit me.
The guy I thought was just a bomb drunk who was hanging around the campaign headquarters.
But in truth, he actually was a spy.
And fortunately for me, a reporter from the Mohamad Speaks of Black Muslim News, they became out from Chicago, an investigator story, and they did a good story.
KPFA didn't air the charges, but I was in a rather tough pickle there for a few minutes, based upon this kind of activity.
But again, that's the kind of thing that you had to live with and go.
In the one time of my life was threatened.
I had to have around the clock secured.
So I just said they knew about a contract on my life.
And it turned out it was an extortion plot, which someone wanted me to pay them some money.
He was eventually arrested by the Perkley Police.
But so there were a few dull moments in the period.
But again, we got changed.
That was one thing.
We made things happen.
Take a quick break for a second.
Do you have your better to be safe than sorry?
The first thing I said to my fiancee was you got to tell me if there's anything in my case.
Yes, absolutely.
That was a pretty adventurous time.
So they got the signature on the petition.
The way recall works is that if you get 25% of the people who voted in the last election to sign a petition, then you forced into an election.
And so they had 18,000 people already that had voted in the election when we were defeated.
And so all they needed to do was organize a campaign with the money from the business community and the conservatives.
And put on the ballot the question, shall the Army be recalled?
Yes or no?
Well, in order to survive once they get those signatures, then you have to get a majority.
So it's no longer the situation where I had won with a plurality, but I never had a majority because the conservatives were still in the majority in Perkley at that time.
And they knew that.
And so I knew that by the time they got those signatures, that it was that that batch answers have defeated the recall, will be rather slim.
Right.
But and I knew that for two and a half years that I was under the specter of that happening.
And it sounds like they were because of the way they could do that.
They were going to recall somebody from your from that ticket.
And a friend of mine, Roger Nash Baldwin, well I knew him because in New York his nephew and I were good friends and he had introduced me to Roger and we had launched a couple of times.
He came out to the Bay Area to visit during the recall and I picked him up and he said, just pull over to the side of the road.
And he said, look, he said, I've been out here and people I had that the information I get is that you're not going to beat this recall unless you tell where your money is coming from.
Because people just don't like that kind of not knowing that kind of thing.
And so that was another factor that I'm sure was on the table.
What had happened was that my friends had closed down the trust as more and more questions began to be asked about the money, especially after I had one and reported that anonymous contribution.
So they had given me $100,000 which they paid to taxes on and I used that money to pay staff.
So I had a staff of well actually as many as 13 people several of them were students so I could get them on work studies so I didn't have to pay them full salary.
Then I had one full time person assigned to me by the Joint Center for Political and Economic Studies back in Washington.
And so I put together this quite competent staff.
So whenever I went to the Council meetings I had these thick books of information because my staff would go out, they would research all of the agenda items, they talk with people in the community.
And there's nothing that brings about change more than information probably used.
And that's what I went in there armed with on the council.
And that helped me to make a difference as a council member.
But by the time of the recall I used up a great deal of that 100 grand.
And I had probably a third of that money left.
Probably not that much but I had to spend most of what I had left fighting the recall.
So by the time the recall was over of course they didn't know it in California but my money was pretty well out anyway.
And I knew that it was going to run out because I wasn't practicing law.
I did as I say have some stipends coming in but I don't think I was at that point still doing the consultant work because it was limited work with the Field Foundation.
So financially the jig was going to be up anyway.
I couldn't have carried on with the same momentum and resources for a full four year term.
And so in some ways it was really gratuitous that they recalled me after two and a half years because I had a tough struggle to carry on the kind of momentum.
And so when they completed the recall I had to decide do I want to stay out here in the Bay Area and practice law?
Do I want to go somewhere else? That's when I made the decision to retire in Dmitris.
And in that limited time the two and a half years you were able to achieve some change to the change last.
Did you stay in touch and see if some of that change persisted in Berkeley, California?
Much of it did. For example we set the pattern of an integrated city hall with the top level staff people that continued.
And as the same thing as opportunities in the police and fire departments that continued.
I took the lead and helping give the garbage workers increased benefits.
What happened was that there was a strike and we had an executive session told our negotiator to offer the union more money for the lower paid workers who were the garbage workers.
But that didn't get conveyed to the garbage workers in the negotiations.
And so they went on strike and so there was an impasse and Kurt McLean who was a black union leader in the Bay Area came to me and said,
you need to take some leadership and call for a resumption to talk.
And so I did. I said I'm going to show up at the negotiating table and I'm asking the union and the garbage workers to do the same, which they did.
And we recommenced the negotiations and two of the other council members joined me.
Well, when we started again we were getting nowhere fast and I called the garbage workers leaders aside and I said, look let's go talk.
And I took them into a side room and I said to them, look, do you realize that we're offering you guys an accelerated increase versus these other guys?
Because the only people there were on strike were the garbage workers but the negotiations were for all of the municipal unions.
Police, fire and engineers and everybody else. They were riding on the backs of the garbage workers who were on strike.
And I told those workers, look, if we go ahead and settle this thing, you'll get more money.
And because we were trying to raise them to a level on a palm with these other city employees, which we did.
And so that came because of that. Well, because when we got to garbage workers, when I pulled their coat out and let them know what was happening and they decided that they weren't going to carry these other unions, Paul Vericalli was the head of the union negotiating for all of them, but he was, he had divided all these there, tough union man.
So anyway, those kind of things were changes that we brought about. Now what has changed since then is the gentrification that in those areas now were blacks lived and what we call the flatlands nearest to the river, to the bay.
And now areas that are largely gentrified where you have, instead of black families living in those areas now, you have a much greater proportion of income whites because the land is so expensive.
And those blacks have sold out many of them so their property and move elsewhere. And so the black population of Berkeley, California has declined substantially from the 25% when I was there.
You know, I was going to be traveling in Berkeley, California, I was an old man. Yeah, I mean, it could be impossible to afford it.
So we're going to jump to Memphis. I wanted to ask about, especially since the anniversaries are happening or coming up about the Civil Rights Act and the Voting Rights Act, and where were you at the time of those pieces of national legislation and what your reaction was?
Give me the year because there was so much happening. 63 and 64. Okay. 64. I was still at clock because I remember as the President Kennedy was assassinated in November of 63.
And it was in the wake of the assassination of President Kennedy that Lyndon B. Johnson took the leadership and gave great momentum to the thrust to pass that legislation.
And I remember him in 65 pushing for the Voting Rights Act. And that was in the wake of Selma and the killing of Viola Liuzzo and Reverend James Reeb.
And I remember watching him on television when he was announcing his support for that and said, we shall overcome. And when I was sitting there watching this white Southern President in his Southern accent, say we shall overcome.
But not just say it, but mean it in terms of putting the weight of the presidency behind getting this legislation passed in 65.
I knew the things that changed in America. I mean with Johnson. Kennedy had been in many ways viewed as the hero, but the real difference came with the shoulder to the wheel work that Lyndon B. Johnson did after the assassination to get that legislation through the Congress.
And with the passage of the Voting Rights Act, I did not feel that the act itself was going to make a momentous change because having seen in Memphis that blacks had to vote but still no money and no power.
And I remember that when all was said done, give them the vote. But what does that mean in terms of fundamental change? And I never really thought and still don't think for that matter.
That voting power, political power, is the be all and end all of the quest for liberation. It is a tool. When I ran for the Berkeley, California City Council, it was not based upon my belief that
the system works. Now the media treated it that way. They said, oh, the radicals have now gone within the system. And they now believe in the system and are going to make the system work.
After our election in Berkeley, California, some young people ran in Madison, Wisconsin, and were elected on progressive platform.
And others of our generation began to mimic this whole notion that we in the Bay Area had developed. And a lot of that was through the strategy and the philosophies refined by the April coalition, the hard work that they had done and said in the past.
We just helped to bring it about in a victorious way. But I didn't, to me, it was opportunities as opposed to believe in the ongoing
and the ability of established political systems to make a difference. So I never looked at the beating of heads in the street and they're going to jail. Those were the things that I knew made a difference that would cause change in this country.
The riots and Watts (riots, August 1965) + Detroit + Newark and in Newark. When people take to the streets and really confront those in authority and bring things to hold. And that was my strategy in Berkeley, California. Now, of course, you have to recognize that those strategies are not lasting. In other words, you've got to be prepared to move from one arena to the other.
If you think that you can take one strategy and stand fast on that strategy and carry forth the progress, then you're in for rude awakening because you've got to be run over. And so you've got to know when the songs and no one to hold them and no one to hold them.
Because they'll eventually figure out how to neutralize what you're doing. But in the meantime, you can make dramatic difference. But the system is not going to change because the political system is basically designed to be used and controlled by the money, power of the country.
Because it's money that you have to have the run for office and to stay in office. And then the communities that you're trying to reach, you have to reach to mechanisms that are controlled by money, communications. And right on down to the workforce. And they've decimated unions. And so you don't have a labor voice that can kind of offset.
And now, in, for example, states like Tennessee, where politics means very little because we've got super majorities in the legislature and a Republican president. And they are now, they are vulcanized in the country with strongholds of right wing power.
And I'm not sure, but that in time, the growth of that power will not again become a majority power in America.
I mean, this is why, yeah, this is what, this is what we're up against. But it's also, I mean, as you say, why a movement needs to be multifaceted. You need to have these fronts. You need to have the judicial front and the WACP and the same time that you have SNCC and protest in the streets.
And I spent 19 years as a, as a trial judge here in Memphis, and 14 additional years as a lawyer, doing which I represent people who were charged with murder and were facing death penalty.
I've tried over a dozen capital cases where my client was facing the chair. And in those cases, I had to work within the system to try to get justice for my client.
I was almost to say I had to thwart the system because lawyers within the judicial system are not looking for justice. We look for victory for our side.
And that's true. If you're planning for lawyer or you're a defense lawyer or if you represent the prosecution or the defense.
When I was representing people facing the chair, justice may have been that, if I'm not, I'm not a believer in capital punishment, but it may have been the many long years in the penetrator.
But if I got someone off with fewer know years, then to me that was gratifying victory because that was my job not to have a just result.
As a judge, however, for 19 years, my role was quite different. It was to assure that the system at least was a level playing field for all sides within that arena.
But I never felt even then that the legal system is a system set up for fundamental justice. It's a system by which you could order disputes and set the rules by which to resolve disputes where people don't have to resort to violence.
And maybe tweak it here and there to make it a little more just.
Yes, but then when you think about it and we look at the legal system, I remember William Kunstler and Arthur Kinoy who came to Memphis when we were open in the Civil Rights Museum in 1991.
And those were two of the premier lawyers and the civil liberties and civil rights struggle. And at that time, they were arguing in their presentations to the groups there that lawyers and activists should take their pleas now to state courts and state systems because the federal system was then federal courts were not responding.
And so it was a matter of where do you fight? Do you fight on the state level? Do you fight on the federal level? It's not that you have any great affinity for either as it relates to change.
So now the kind of advocacy that may have been developed to go into the state systems and fight there or even in the 1960s to go into the federal systems and fight, well now we can't go into the federal system and fight because you've got a Supreme Court with a majority that has no sympathy for the change that people need and are fighting for.
And while you do have some federal appeals courts that are more sympathetic, many of them are not. And on the trial court level in the federal system, you may or may not get a good conscience judge.
So while in the past, we could say that the judiciary is a means of change. But if you look at what's happening with them, with the changes they're making on the Citizens United v. FEC, where they're letting corporations now have complete ownership of the communications and electoral machinery that makes a difference in this country with unlimited money.
Then the judiciary is open in the way for that. The Bush v. Gore decision, which was a coup d'etat, judicial coup d'etat against the will of the majority of the people. And then I saw Justice Antonin Scalia, say on television, within the last year or so, where people need to just quote, get over it.
And so that's kind of the judicial attitude. So getting the voting rights act.
Yes. And so you just have to look at, well, where do we turn to now? And in some ways, we're just as desperate. I mean, there's some of us a little bit of off.
We've got a few more material things. We've got educationally. There's a decline in the number of African Americans, for example, proportionally that it get into the major colleges and universities.
When I was coming up, we had at least the idealism that one generation would be a step better in its hard work and achievements than our parents. But that's no longer the case.
And so I tend to sometimes use the analogy of Hegel's dialectic, in which there's a notion that there's a cycle and that things calm down. And then in the calm oppression makes its raises its head again. And injustice gets worse that people then rebel.
And out of that rebellion, you get progress and change. And there's a continuing cycle of the thesis things as they are, the antithesis, when people revolt and the synthesis, some progress comes and things get bad again.
And so as it relates to the Voting Rights Act in 65, as it relates to the Civil Rights Act, the Public Commodation Act, those things were important changes. And they were important landmarks.
But they never struck me as being major game changers. Even when Title VII, Fair Employment, Equal Employment Opportunities Commission, and was passed in the 64, became effective in 65, I was never so naive to think that we were truly going to see the elimination of racism and employment opportunities in this country.
And we don't see it even today. The barriers are different. I mean, they're not outright racial in the same way, but the result is the same.
Can I ask you, Peter, to give a little bit on the side subject of this, which is the one great game splats and made his imprisonment populations?
I was thinking the same thing.
The individual person can be speak to...
or removes people from their ability to vote as well.
I don't even know what the question is, but do you know more about the different systems at work than I do?
Could you give any hope for reversing the situation?
I think that the explosion of blacks in the penal institutions is part of the sense of...
This country has destroyed systematically the sense of value and self-worth among minorities.
And we kid ourselves, and I think it's unfair for White America to think that in the last 50 years, say, since the Brown case of 60 years,
that suddenly we can erase all of the ills and evil that arose from three centuries of denial and exploitation and defeat.
And as black families were destroyed in terms of broken up and not allowed to flourish, where black manhood was not allowed to be self-respecting,
the impact of that has been devastating on the psyche of black America.
I was reading an article about the psychological impact of everyday racism that works on black people,
because even among whites who don't mean to be offensive, they create attention in their own interaction with blacks, whether it's on an elevator or in a department store passing down a dark and street.
On up to who you prefer when you make a job or who you prefer among your associates.
But that creates an ongoing tension among black people that adds even one study at Columbia University to our health problems,
it creates issues of blood pressure and illness.
My point is that the pathology of blacks in prison is not just because you've got a lot
of young black men who are irresponsible, and there are a lot of them that are irresponsible,
that leads to, I mean, as they me, it causes them there in conservation, an attempted
robbery or burglary or what they call black-home black crime even.
But if you look behind that as to why are they in this condition, why do they have so little
sense of investment in life and in the society around them?
Because they have not been exposed to the better things.
Those things are alien to them.
And you have to create an entirely new sense of cultural and personal awareness, which
requires investment into the human resources in these communities.
This country is not prepared to do.
And so the refuse of our ills and of our mistreatment of these centuries is there that becomes
the feral that nourishes this continuing nihilism and this continuing walk-in and out of prisons
about young people.
And it's a justice system that becomes the gatekeeper that revolves them in and out.
But the ones that come in with these pathologies leave with the same pathologies only to return.
And this expectation that they will be incarcerated, that's normal.
Because if you look at why are people, when I was growing up, there were cases of blacks
who would be violent toward each other or family.
But often that was family of friend and violence.
Today you have a lot of violence, senseless violence that emanates from gangs or from the
attempt to imitate gangs.
And what causes a young person in his or her teens to associate with an organization that
has so little respect for another person's life or suffering?
Or their own life because they surely know that there is a price to pay, but it gives
them a sense of bigness and of some sense of worth that they can identify with these criminal
elements, these gangs.
And the bigger, the more criminal they become at times, the bigger they feel within this
disease infrastructure that they've become a part of.
And society wants to condemn them looking at the end result, not recognize in its complicity
and creating this monster that's out there and this continuing to grow.
And it can be reversed, but it takes not only resources, but it takes a different attitude.
And white people have got to stop being defensive and being indeniable.
You cannot eliminate generations of racism in 50 years.
And people who say, well, I don't see color, or just liars.
I mean, you have to see color every day and you may as well admit it.
And then ask yourself, what does it mean when I see it in any given situation?
And am I doing the positive in this situation as I see this color?
My color?
His color, her color?
Or am I creating negative energies that are making the situation worse?
So, Lord, you're in denial and a quick to take offense and say, oh, well, he's over the
substitute.
Right.
That was a great answer.
And I mean, it's interesting that the moment of the Obama election and the Obama presidency
plays into this, right, because there was a feeling of this as a band-aid or a panacea
or a healthy one, to describe it.
That's when we heard so much of this, pardon me, but BS about beyond race.
And my wife and I were in the Gulf on a cruise the night of the election.
We had voted early.
And I'm frankly glad that I was not ashore where I would have to contend with my, with the
difficulty personally of knowing that in spite of all this exhilaration, that the next
morning was going to bring the same challenges and the same battles as the morning before.
And so I imagine even more because then, as you said, then you've got some people who
are excusing themselves or patting themselves on the back.
Absolutely.
So, the problem is, pretending the problem has been solved somehow.
Sorry, tender up.
No, it is.
That's it.
Very interesting.
Okay.
We need to talk about the Civil Rights Center and then we'll wrap up in count.
Thank you for giving us so much of your time.
I'm sorry to take over.
You wanted to check by.
Yeah, of course.
Of course, let me.
Okay.
All right.
So you return to your hometown in 1974.
1974.
Okay.
And start practicing while I hear.
Yes.
My brother was practicing here since 65 and so I cheer at office spaces, the space with him
and from 65 on actually until I was elected judge from 74 rather than until I was elected
judge in 1990.
And when I first got back to Memphis, I knew that people would be a little concerned that
here's this crazy radical in California.
So I, in addition to practicing law, I wrote a weekly column in the morning paper each
Monday in RP at peace.
And that gave me, and I did that for seven years and that gave me a chance to kind of level
out the perception of me as opposed to letting people perceive me as being this while I
had California radical.
So and that, and I thought was helpful.
And in 1983, I ran for mayor because I felt that there was a need to introduce my kind
of thought in the process.
There were two other black candidates and one white candidate in that race, the major
candidates and papers treated the four of us as major candidates.
But for me it was an opportunity to advocate the white candidate won and that was likely
to happen in any event because of the strength that he brought into the race.
And at that point we had not yet elected a black mayor in Memphis but that was a four
grade that I undertook in 83.
A continent malaw practice and then as I said it was elected judge.
Well back in 82 while I was practicing law I ran into Walter L. Bailey Sr who was the black
man that owned the Lorraine Motel motel.
And Mr. Bailey had first had the same name as my father, they were both Walter Hill
Bailies. And so when I grew up, people often thought it was my family, the Lorraine Motel Motel,
even though it was a different world to Bailie. And so I saw Walter L. Bailey Sr, I was going into a
little neighborhood, convenience store, a bibeer. And there was a London mat next door to it.
And Walter L. Bailey Sr had been in that London mat to wash it, to do his laundry. And it was down here,
at Vans and a few blocks from where the Lorraine Motel Motel is. And I really had never been that much
involved with, I thought much about the Lorraine Motel. This would have been, when I first met Walter L. Bailey Sr,
let's see, the foreclosure on the Motel was in 1982. I met Walter L. Bailey Sr around 1979, I think,
somewhere over there about. And he was struggling to try to keep the doors of the place
open. His wife had had a stroke the night of the assassination, and she died three days later.
And she had helped him to run the business. So Walter L. Bailey Sr continued to operate it. And so I
introduced myself to him, and this was, as I said, late 70s. Had it been a sort of a shrine of
sorts, and people come to visit? Oh yes. After the assassination, people were continuing to
make pilgrimages to the Lorraine Motel Motel. But it was basically a run down motel.
I know that the Poor People's Campaign announced it start there with Reverend Jesse Jackson and others.
Yes. So it did have some residents, but as a establishment, it had really run down.
Yes. Well, there were three buildings on the property, one of which was an older motel building
that was closed. And then there was a second hotel building, which was attached to the office,
and that was basically closed. And the only one of the three buildings that was largely functional
as a motel was the L-shaped building where Dr. King was heading on the balcony up. And
much of the business there, at least I'd say probably have a prostitutes, because after the
assassination, that area of downtown was really decaying or had decayed. And there were no
businesses of any consequence in that area. And so it was a dark and seedy area, and there were
prostitutes up in down the street and using the rooms of the Lorraine Motel. And Mr. Bailey was trying to
make ends meet as best he could. And he had created a little bit of a shrine in the room that Dr.
King had last occupied, where he kept the dishes of Dr. King last eight from, which I now have,
actually. And he kept the library of his wife on display, and he kept
shoes of his wife that were going to display case next to the dishes. And people would come and
go into that room. And it was small, simple, but very hallowed. And it was open to the public,
and there was no charge. People would leave donations. But that was there as far as any kind of
shrine at the site. Otherwise, he was trying to run a motel. And I incorporated for him a
nonprofit group, the Lorraine Motel King Shrine Foundation. And they were to then try to raise money to
build a significant shrine there at the Lorraine Motel. He couldn't get any support. There had been
people from time to time who'd come in from out of town, or maybe locally say, we're going to do
this to the Lorraine Motel. We're going to raise money. None of it panned out. And so he was trying to keep
the doors open just with the business that he could get on a day-to-day basis. And in fact,
I went with him one day as he took his mortgage payment out to the mortgage holders home. And
Walter L. Bailey Sr and I went out there. Harry Sauer was the mortgage holder. And I remember Walter L. Bailey Sr
pulling out a little small brown paper bag that he had his cash in. And he counted out his
payment to Mr. Sauer there. And they chatted for a bit. We left. But that was the level of
business operation at that time. And so when he couldn't get any traction, any interest in the
Shrine Foundation, I then did go to a local white businessman, a writer who had a construction
company. And that's our EITR. And I said to Mr. Reiter, look, come on down, let's look at the Lorraine Motel.
And let's put together some money and buy it privately and develop it. And he looked at it and
brought some other partners now and they look at it and they said, we're not going to do it.
So that was about all I could think of to do at that time. Again, this was nothing public because I
was not prone to any kind of public campaigns. And I wasn't that vested in the issue for that matter.
And so Walter L. Bailey Sr, Mr. Sauer initiated foreclosure on the place and Walter L. Bailey Sr then had to file
bankruptcy in order to stop the foreclosure. And that happened in April of the early spring of 1982.
Walter L. Bailey Sr got an order from the bankruptcy court to stall the foreclosure. And when that happened,
the black owned, not black owned, but the black oriented radio station, WDIA here,
launched a campaign to raise money to save the Lorraine Motel. And Chuck Scruggs, who was a general manager there,
and two or three of his staff people were going to organize a major fundraising effort to buy the Lorraine Motel
from Walter L. Bailey Sr. And that's when they called me and asked me to join their effort. And I incorporated
the initial foundation, the Lorraine Motel, what we actually called it, the Martin Luther King Neffes Memorial
Foundation. But the effort of the radio station that was going to raise the money to buy the Lorraine Motel
directly from Walter L. Bailey Sr, fell through. They were unable to raise any significant money. And so
after two delays from the bankruptcy judge, he allowed the foreclosure to proceed. Now we had
done all that we could. By this time, now I am out publicly with the radio station and the
people about a reason money to save the Lorraine Motel. And I really felt very bad because it was not my
approach on things to get out into a big public campaign without at least seeing a reasonable
chance of success. But I was banking on the radio station being able to deliver, which they could.
And so the foreclosure went ahead. And the sale was on December the 13th of 1982.
And the mortgage was about $153,000. I believe. And Mr. Sauré's son Raymond Sauer did the bidding
at the courthouse on the day of the auction, which is a 12-new one. And I bid for my nonprofit group.
Well, I went to the auction and I think I had about $50,000 that we'd raised in our different
radio thons and everything we could do. So that was well short of what we needed to get close to
the mortgage holders mortgage. And he could bid up to that. And if no one matched it, then he could
walk away with the place. Well, the Union leadership had promised that they would give $25,000 to ask me
the Union. And I was on pins and needles. And Jim Smith, who was ahead of the Union locally,
showed up 30 minutes before the auction. And he had a check for $25,000. And so that put us at,
let's see, we had 25 from the Union. We still were well short of, we ended up with 140,000.
So I said we had 50, we must have had 65,000 going into the auction because the 25,000 from the Union
put us at 90. And one of the leaders of my little small group, the Martin Luther King
Memphis Memorial Foundation, was a black lawyer, A.W. Willis Jr Jr. And he came to me on the steps of
court. I said, look, we can borrow $50,000 from Tri-State Bank, that was the black owned bank.
And Jesse H. Turner Sr was at the auction, who was the head of the bank, and was one of my group.
So he said, well, I'll loan the money if you get me to guarantee us. And so I went to Jim Smith,
the Union, I said, Jim, I said, well, you'll guarantee $25,000. He said he would. And then I went
to Paul Shapiro, who had a cosmetics company, and I said to Paul, Paul, well, you guarantee $25,
which he said he would. And so with their commitment there on the court house steps, we had another
$50,000. This is all happening right before the auction. Just minutes before the auction.
And so when the auction started, I had $140,000. And so as the bidding started, I was bidding.
And initially there were probably, half dozen or more people bidding. But by the time the
bidding got to $100,000, it dropped off to just be a sour in me. And I'd make a bid, usually an
increment, say, of $5,000, and he would increase it by $5. And this went on until I got near to the
140, which I knew was all that I had. And when I finally did get, well, actually I went over the 140,
but I started dropping the bid down to $1,000 increments. And so he kept bidding over me. And I
finally got to $144,000. And I said, and not a penny more. And he did bid after that. And so
the hammer fell at $144,000. And so I got home that night and I called Jack Belz, the owner of
the Peabody Hotel here. And I had been able to call on him from time to time for small support,
not financial, but if I needed a meeting place at the Peabody or something. So I told him I needed
$4,000. And he raised that for me overnight. And so I had to appear at the auction company the
next day with the cashiest check for $144,000, which we did. And so we bought it. And so here I am.
I'm practicing law. Chuck Scruggs says a radio station man, just turned into a bank man. So none of us
were in this thing to build a motel or run a shrine. And so what do you do now? We own it. And so we
turned to Bailey and said to Mr. Bailey, look, you continue to run this place. And you don't have to
pay us any money. Whatever you make you keep to pay for maintenance and whatever you try to keep
the prostitutes from being so aggressive. We knew that it wasn't going to stop it. I mean, couldn't stop.
And so he continued to operate it from the time we bought it in 82 until finally we got the
project funded in 1986. But we didn't start construction until 88 when they closed the Lorraine Motel
and the construction actually began. Well, once we bought it, I got a letter from Mrs. King's lawyer
in Atlanta. And the lawyer said, if you don't drop out King's name from the project, we're going to
sue. And so at that point, I'd reported to the board and recommended that we drop it, which they
did. And we renamed the foundation, the Lorraine Motel Civil Rights Museum Foundation, which is the name of
the organization now that currently runs to museum. And but actually it was really a blessing in
disguise that I'd gotten that letter from Mrs. King because I had not made any overtures to them.
Although I later was told that Chuck Scruggs's at the radio station had apparently had some
conversation with her before I got involved, which didn't go very well. And then that might have
created some difficulties. I don't know. Because as I said, I didn't have any until I got that letter,
I had had no contact with the Kings. But by getting that letter and by dropping Dr. King's name,
it then freed me from having to be involved, would having to go back and forth to the King family
to discuss what we were doing or to get their approval on anything. So she made a couple of
comments to the media that our project was morbid that we shouldn't be focusing on the place of
death. And I didn't get into a debate with her about that. We just kept going. Now here we are.
We're on in the Lorraine Motel. We've got no money. We're older, banked 50,000. So it was at this point
that I mean none of the others really had much of an idea of what we're going to do with it.
My idea was came from my involvement with the movement. And I knew that it was a place of tremendous
magnetism that people would always come from around the world. And having been privileged to be a
first-hand observer and participant in a very dynamic civil rights movement, it was clear to me that
the thing would be to wet the spirit and the strength of that movement and the story of that
movement in the most dynamic way to this site and to build an exhibition there that would make the
visit a part of the movement because the movement by this time was known longer. But I knew I had seen
how engaging the movement was to young people. I would bring people in and get them motivated and
convert them to warriors. And so I felt that we don't have a movement but if we create one here
we can perhaps continue to churn out new activists. And so we sent out, I got some
architects to volunteer at their time to help come up with some very rough plans. And with that
I got the, I asked belts to give me a room at the Peabody to bring in some government leaders and
they gave us $50,000 which we used to ask for proposals from consultants. And we had half
dozen different proposals that came in and among those was a proposal for Benjamin Lawless. And we had a
three-member committee myself, John Elkenton, who was a white developer and eight-every-willis. And
we looked at those proposals. And when I saw the proposal that Ben had and Ben's proposal was
largely the same exhibition design that is in the museum now. Now it's been done now but that's
been the museum for the last 21 years. I saw that this was someone that had immediately captured
the spirit and the energy that I wanted to see conveyed in that museum. The way he had laid out
the exhibits to make them interactive, not so much interactive, but make them dynamic with
voice over music and photographs to bring the life. Now I told them that I wanted to burn the
bus and put it in there because I wanted people to have a feeling of being on the scenes. I wanted
them even if they could to smell the tear gas. And we had the sounds of barking dogs and what have
you in the Birmingham exhibit. And so with the design that Ben created, because we then hired him
on this basis of his proposal, gave him the $50,000. He came back with a much more detailed plan for
the museum and a price tag of $8.8 million. So I said to Ben, well all right, Ben, how have we
going to find $8.8 million? He said, well, get the state to give you half and get the city
in Canada to give you half each or quarter 25%. So I went to the Willis and I and Scrooge, I don't
know, I think he was with that. I know Willis was. We met with the leader of the county government.
He said no. The city government leader I could even get a meeting with. And so then Willis had
gotten a black and a legislature to have introduced a bill to give us $10 million. And it was just
lean and legislature nothing has been done on it. But I knew that we were at a dead end. So I called
the Republican. That I knew locally because Alexander was a Republican governor. And I said, can you
find out where the bill is? And he checked and he said the bill is nowhere. It's just up there.
So I called the legislature to introduce that. So I said, Roscoe, I said, we need to get that
bill moving. And then we, A.W. and I, and the staff person that had been assigned to work with us
from a government agency went to Nashville. We started lobbying the legislature. And we went from
office to office and talking with the legislature and Ben Lollis came in from Washington. We met with
the Speaker-to-House, Speaker-to-Senate. And we argued, we didn't argue with him. We made
presentations about what we were trying to do. And so they saw it as a Martin Luther King project.
And so that was that was a positive for us at that time. We had a different,
Democratic-controlled legislature. And there were some people who had some misgivings that they
thought it would create antagonisms and tension. And I would argue, or say to them, no, this is just
to inspire people. Although I was hoping that it would create these antagonisms and tension.
That was the underlying idea. Did they see tourism dollars too or at that point or not? No,
that wasn't even mentioned. They saw it as something black people wanted. It was a king project.
Okay. In fact, one day I went by one legislature's office as we were lobbying. And he said, Mr.
Bailey, limit to the fact that we speak frankly with your taste on these. And he said, we were
talking, me and some other legislators here last night at dinner. And they said, these black
legislators and most of the blacks in legislature were from Memphis. Still are. We had probably a dozen
black legislators from Memphis and the rest of the state combined only had two or three.
And so he said, these these legislators, black legislators, want this money for your king project.
But they also got their own projects that they want. You can't have everything now. They tell
us that this is their number one priority. You can get your money. So I saw these black
legislators in their desk. It fell as limited to you, but the white man told me. He said, now you all
got these other projects. And I respect that. But you're going to have to put these on a back burner.
And let them know that this is a number one priority. And to their credit they did. And when the
black legislators led to be known to their white colleagues, that they wanted this king money.
At that point, we were down to ask for a 4.4 million, which would be half, half of 8.8, we need it.
And so with the black legislature, solidly behind it, the speaker of the Senate was behind it.
The speaker of the House was behind it, both Democrats. It passed something like 83 to 17 in the
House in 33 in nothing in the Senate. In fact, I was in the Senate gallery when it passed.
And one of the I asked to look at the agenda of one of the eights that was in the gallery while I was.
And someone had written by that item for the Lorraine Motel, this bill is going to pass
anyways to vote your conscience. And it passed 33 in nothing in the Senate.
So we left there with 4.4 million dollars, came back to Memphis, and then gathered the local
leaders and said, look, we got half the money. I brought in some legislators from Nashville.
We need to have the other half from you. And so the county mayor, Paul, but he finally came on
board. We got the other 4 million locally. Then the question came up. We got 8.8 million dollars.
And we were meeting in Nashville at this point.
So raised from local business people?
No, 2.2 from the city government, 2.2 from the county government, and 4.4 from the state.
Okay. No, we didn't get the only money we got from local businesses was Paul Shapiro,
who I put on a board who gave us 10,000 dollars. That was it. That's for local business.
Everything else came from government. Yeah.
And so then, AWS and I, well, AWS was suffering from cancer actually.
So ultimately, he had to stop working on the project. But up until that point, he was with me when
we would go to Nashville on most of these trips. And he was with me when I was sitting at the table
with representatives of the three governments in Nashville. And the question came up,
well, we can't give all this money to this nonprofit group talking about our organization.
We'd have to give it to a government entity. City of Memphis didn't want it. Of course,
this was a white mayor at the time. This would have been 86.
County didn't want it. White leadership. So I said, well, we'll give title to the state if the
state will build the museum. Because my organization still own the property. And so the state said,
well, we'll take it. Now, the condition was that we'll give you the title. If you'll build this
museum according to the plans that we have here, which were the plans that law said designed.
So they agreed that they would do it. City and County agreed that they would sit in there
2.2 million each to the state. And thus it became and is the only state on the museum in Memphis.
But the state took the title because sitting I was kind of happy with that because I figured that
with limit political interference as we went along with local political interference. So we then
once we got the money in place, as I said, I was about 86, then I had to meet by this time.
It was being alone because Willis was no longer able to keep going to Nashville. So I would then
side meeting with the state architect. We had one bit of a flare up because the law
is that recommended a white architect for the project here locally. And I was back in his
demand and I supported that one he wanted. Well, one of the black legislators didn't know I said,
I want my man who was also a white architect. And so with the standoff between the two of them,
because at least our plan had had a collaboration with the black architectural firm in Nashville,
the state said, well, we'll give the job to the black architectural firm in Nashville.
So the black firm in Nashville got the job, McKissack & McKissack. But with the condition that I
extracted from the state that they would put the state architect largely in charge of the project,
because this was a major project that I wanted to make sure was going to be done right. So Mike
Fitz was the state architect actually took control of the project. And so we had to do all about meetings
and planning in his office in Nashville where we proceeded to send out bids for contractors and
design, there's no lot. So everything was then being done with me traveling into Nashville,
lawless coming in from Washington, high school from Kansas City, the architects are in Nashville.
Meanwhile, you're still practicing. I'm still practicing. You're burning the candle.
Yeah. And so and I got a board which hadn't been coming to board meetings, but then as the project
was the company out, they started coming to meetings and wanting to know what's going on and
where do we get input. And and basically I was filibuster and then holding them at bay because I
didn't want them to have input because we had designed this thing. We knew what we were going to do.
We had to team that was doing it. And I didn't want to have to then deal with the politics that,
well, should you have this person in the exhibit or this person in the exhibit or this theme of
that thing. And so I would basically stonewall the board. And then they wanted to have new
elections and bylaw changes because they were trying to figure out some way to get a handle on
how to control this process. It was moving and then moving real fast. And my objective was to keep
them out of it, that the people, the team that we were working with in Nashville. So at this
and so at that point, and this was as construction got underway and was being built,
they were getting mad at me some of them on the board. I had some supporters. We had a board of
probably 15 people. I had maybe six or seven that were good strong supporters.
About four whites, they were on the fence, but when they saw the tension, they saw an opportunity,
at least one of them, a millionaire member of the board, to step into a vacuum there and align
with one of these factions and ultimately align himself with the faction that was against me
because he knew that I wouldn't allow him control of this organization,
whereas the others didn't have anything ready to bring to the table to withstand his money in power.
And that's J.R. "Pitt" Hyde III, who now chairs the executive committee of the museum and basically controls the
museum. But what I would do is the board means would sometimes break up in disarray. I mean,
rather than have them vote on things that would create problems, I would be involved and he did
discussions and arguments with the board and people would just get so frustrated and tired and they
threw up a hand and walked away. And then I could return to the common meetings in Nashville
where we were continuing to put this project together. And so my objective, man, let me get this
thing done and through before they get the control that they're after. And so by the time it opened,
we had built this and built it right and built it, but some of them furious with me and will finally
move in forward to get bilateral changes in the election. And this is the better to ask forgiveness
than permission. And then Benjamin L. Hooks was the one that he had been on the board for, let's say,
this by this time it was 91 when we opened the museum and he'd been on the board for probably at
least five, six years, but it had never been to a meeting. But a couple of the people on the board
who were close to him, it talked to him in New York and got him to agree that he would serve as
the president if they had enough votes to elect him as opposed to me. And when I was trying to
strategize on how to forestall this, which was, he said they're going to be a losing effort,
but I call Ben, who professed that he knew nothing about the plans underfoot. And yet when I got
to the board meeting, he had a letter from him saying that if they voted, they voted him in,
he'd take the job. And so by this time the museum has been opened for six months.
And so they voted in a nine to six vote to elect Ben as the president of the board. And they were
and they put the white millionaire chairman of the executive committee. And they were going to
have me to serve only executive committee, but I had my letter of statement of resignation from the
board already prepared, which I read that night and resigned from the board. Because I,
by that time I knew I had no strength to try to have any, I mean, I'd have to start
from scratch when any new agenda because my idea was to move from the museum to a place of action.
That's why when I opened the museum, I brought in Bob Moses, Julian Bond, John Lewis, all of those
activists from the movement. Because my view was that I was going to use those people and use that
place as a center for their energies and to build new energies to carry on for the movement,
which is not what it is now. Now it's basically a corporate, most of the boys controlled by
corporate people who, I mean, some of them are black, but they still represent interest
corporations. And that's where the money now that fuels the museum comes from. It's no longer
self-controlled. And you had said that you originally wanted to call it the center rather than the
museum. Yes, national civil rights center. But I used the word museum and one about meetings in
national, I told our group. I said, let's change it to museum because we still, periodically, I'd
still have to go before the City Council or the County Commission for different approvals because
at one point we had to get additional money. We had to go before the State Building Commission and
Nashville to get different contracts approved. And so we were still in political waters.
And I knew that there was still an uneasiness about where this thing was ultimately headed.
And I thought that by calling it a museum, it would give it a more neutral appearance and create
less problems for us. But it wasn't my idea to really have a museum. And it was my idea to
have the movement represented there in those exhibits as the beginning point for people to become
re-energized and create a new spirit of activism. And you feel that that hasn't happened?
No, not to or not to the extent that you would have had that at all. And I, who now controls the
board, told me, well, that's what you said. That's not what the museum's for. If you want to do that,
you need to build your own museum. When we were down there today, we heard the plans described for
the new building and that there would be that aspect to it. That at the end of all the exhibits,
you would be sort of inspired as, or asked, what are you going to do?
Well, you can ask that, yes. But that's not the same thing as having the planning going on there
at the site. I mean, how can you, let's face it, the problems of America, the challenge of change,
progressive change in America is still to tackle the corporations. Now, how are you going to have
an institution that has now been taken over by the corporations, federal express, international
paper, AutoZone Inc, which had been sued for major racial discrimination, which is one
of the, and in fact, at the time that these discriminations, discrimination was going on,
J.R. "Pitt" Hyde III was the chairman of the corporation. First Tennessee bank, I mean, these are the corporations
that are seated at the table at the board. And so, corporations, I mean, it's not just the museum.
I mean, this is happening, this is happening across the entire movement. We talked earlier
about the foundations. They didn't extract a pound of flesh from the integrity of the movement.
They stood to the side and thrived on our independence. They didn't try to tell Chavez or King,
I mean, they may have asked, I mean, and they had their own ideas of things they wanted to find,
such as Les Dunbar, wanting to see the children's defense fund, but he was a big sport of Marion
Wright-Adleman. But it's a whole different scenario now, the corporations are the ones that are
doing the fundee. And that's why the movement has basically been killed, not just at the museum,
but the civil rights movement itself, the NAACP. When Michael Bloomberg wants to talk about limits on
fast food, the NAACP says, wait a minute, we don't need any limits on a beast is not a problem,
that's an essence for the museum, because they're getting money from some of these fast food
giants. And so it's a monster. That's why when I said earlier, and I'll say the same thing about
the museum and about civil rights organizations that I said about politics, institutions are only
useful to the extent that you can use them to make change. At some point, they become obsolete
in terms of your objective, and you have to create new forms to bring about change.
Or not only obsolete, but obstacles. Absolutely.
That was terrific. Should we end there? Or should we probably end there?
Well that's right. Because we've taken up hours of your time.
Oh well, but it's been my privilege. It's been an absolute pleasure. Thank you so much for doing that.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.